voilà bonjour à toutes et à tous chers
collègues mesdames messieurs la
commission d'enquête visant à établir
les raisons de la perte de souveraineté
et d'indépendance énergétique de la
France organise aujourd'hui trois
auditions avant la suspension de travaux
pour la trêve des confiseurs nous
commençons par l'audition de Monsieur
Xavier pièces classiques
excusez-moi
je vais y arriver ici à la fin de
l'entretien président du directoire du
réseau de transport d'électricité
choisi que nous vous remercions d'avoir
répondu rapidement à notre sollicitation
car nous avons en effet souhaité vous
entendre pour recueillir votre avis sur
les enjeux relatifs à la souveraineté à
l'indépendance énergétique et dans votre
cas plus spécifiquement électrique de de
la France les gestionnaires de réseaux
ont désormais un rôle essentiel en
matière d'approvisionnement nous avons
d'ailleurs hier entendu votre
prédécesseur tout en regrettant que
faute de temps nous ne puissions pas
interroger les premiers responsables de
du RTE dans la configuration définie en
2010 par la loi relative à la nouvelle
organisation du marché d'électricité je
rappelle que la séparation des activités
de production d'une part et de transport
et de distribution de l'électricité
d'autres parts a constitué une exigence
des instances européennes EDF a été
ainsi conduit à filialiser ses activités
de distribution gérer désormais par
enedis et ses activités de transport
d'électricité confiée à RTE la gestion
du réseau de transport fait intervenir
outre RTE d'autres indices entités
l'état la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie qui a le statut d'autorité
indépendante et l'Agence européenne de
coopération des régulateurs d'énergie
les interconnexions dans le cadre du
marché européen on en effet été souhaité
et développé ces dernières années elles
permettent d'organiser des flux qui se
traduisent en importation ou
exportations la crise actuelle mais en
évidence l'intérêt d'une telle
solidarité européenne
les mécanismes tant pour le financement
des investissements que pour le choix
des tracés ou les conditions de
négociation des achats et des ventes
demeurent toutefois opaque pour la
plupart des citoyens français comme
européens
l'initiative chinoise de 2016 d'une
nouvelle route de la soie appliquée à
l'électricité pour par ailleurs laisser
dubitatif quant à la préservation d'une
souveraineté ou d'une indépendance
électrique de l'Europe en toute état de
cause il convient de relever que les
interconnexions garantissent un
approvisionnement d'électrons mais ne
donne aucune assurance quant à leur
provenance
alors source en tout cas charbon gaz
hydraulique ou autre énergie
renouvelable ou nucléaire
rTE est en situation de monopole régulée
un contrat de service public définit les
priorités de l'État celles qui
s'imposent aux gestionnaires de réseau
en 2017 la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement et l'équilibre du
système électrique était affirmé comme
priorité à côté de la transition
énergétique celui conclut en 2022 évoque
toujours la transition énergétique et
consacre le premier le principe de
résilience on peut se demander si les
termes utilisés traduisent un changement
d'orientation voilà peut-être une
première interrogation qui animera nos
débat ce matin quoi qu'il en soit dans
le contexte actuel de
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
est essentiel monsieur piéchazi que vous
allez sûrement nous rassurer de ce point
de vue là mais l'équilibre du rhizo ne
se limite pas à une question
d'approvisionnement le développement des
énergies renouvelables nécessitent ainsi
pour le réseau des investissements
importants
trentaine de milliards sont prévus d'ici
2035 notamment pour les raccordements et
le stockage auquel s'ajoutent des
interventions complexes pour leur mise
en réseau en quelque sorte les charges à
faire entes au réseau sont par ailleurs
principalement couvertes par un tarif
administré le Turp or selon le dernier
rapport de la Cour des comptes portant
sur RTE les lois de 2017 relatives à la
fin des recherches et de l'exploitation
des hydrocarbures et de 2018 relative à
l'état au service d'une société de
confiance
relative à l'état au service d'une
société de confiance ont opéré un
transfert de charges que la Cour n'avait
pas été en mesure d'évaluer votre
audition monsieur piéchazic permettra
certainement de nous donner quelques
éclaircissements de ce point de vue là
avant de vous laisser la parole pour un
premier propos liminaire il me revient
en vertu de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires de vous demander de bien
vouloir prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité et rien que la vérité on
sait en conséquence de quoi je vous prie
de bien vouloir lever la main droite et
dire je le jure je le jure écoutez je
vous laisse la parole pour un propos
introductif merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président rTE est
issu d'une du service transport d'EDF et
en fait l'indépendance de RTE est une
conséquence de l'ouverture des marchés
ouverture des marchés voulu par le par
le droit communautaire et donc RTE c'est
détaché de DF à partir du début des
années 2000 je tiens à dire que nous
sommes à délégataire de service public
que pour cela nous avons un contrat de
concession dont un dont le cahier des
charges est approuvé par décret vous
l'avez dit nous sommes à monopole
réguler
monopole régulier je précise indépendant
donc nous sommes indépendants d'EDF qui
n'a pas le contrôle
de de RTE de ce point de vue puisque
nous parlerons monsieur le Président
beaucoup je suppose de nos études
prévisionnels je tenais à le signaler
alors nous avons plusieurs
caractéristiques déjà on est une grosse
entreprise un gros industriel un peu
moins de 10000 salariés un petit peu
moins de 5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires par an on est un opérateur de
réseau donc on est un gestionnaire
d'infrastructures un gestionnaire
d'actifs plus de 100000 km de lignes 250
milles pilones 2700 postes électriques
en exploitation notamment avec nos
collègues d'enedis de ce point de vue là
nous avons des gros enjeux pour pour les
années qui viennent parce que vous savez
que la transition énergétique est la
modification du mix de production va
conduire à des investissements réseau
vous l'avez dit conséquent nous sommes
aussi en charge de l'exploitation du
système électrique français mais aussi
européen puisque le système électrique
via les interconnexions et connectées
nous fonctionnons tous à 50 Hertz en
Europe à la même fréquence
pour cela nos enjeux dans les années qui
viennent sont bien évidemment aussi du
point de vue de l'exploitation du
système et de la sécurité
d'approintégrer toutes les nouvelles
formes de production mais aussi toutes
les nouvelles formes de consommation et
de développer nous y reviendrons je
pense les flexibilités dont nous aurons
besoin demain et enfin nous avons une
fonction d'éclaireur du débat public et
des décisions publiques qui est une
mission légale et qui est prévue par
l'article l104
l141-8 pardon du code de l'énergie voilà
alors
je devine que je ne suis pas là pour
parler des volumes de CAPEX sur
l'infrastructure donc je me suis hyper
admis de prendre l'initiative de vous
parler de nos études prévisionnelles que
nous produisons depuis le début des
années 2000
ce que je veux commencer par dire c'est
que ce sont toutes des études de
sécurité d'approvisionnement et le
fondamental de nos études
prévisionnelles c'est de dire que ce
sont des études de sécurité
d'approvisionnement notre rôle et de
regarder si la France garantit sa
sécurité d'approvisionnement du point de
vue de l'électricité et tout ça est
organisé autour d'un critère des trois
heures trois heures de défaillance des
marchés donc toutes nos études sont
organisées autour de ce critère qui je
rappelle est défini par les pouvoirs
publics qu'est-ce que ça veut dire trois
heures de défaillance ça veut dire qu'en
probabilité il faut que le système
électrique il faut que les marchés
équilibrent naturellement le système
électrique sauf en probabilité pendant
trois heures par an voilà le fondamental
des textes et ça ce n'est que
l'application du droit
alors
ces études elles sont publiées elles
sont toujours publiques elles ne sont
jamais remises à des pouvoirs publics un
gouvernement nous les publions nous les
présentons et elles ont pour but donc
d'informer des prérequis d'une part et
des conséquences
d'un certain nombre de politiques
publiques et de la transformation de
notre environnement énergétique en
matière de sécurité d'approvisionnement
donc ça renvoie à des politiques donc
d'évolution de la consommation et ça
renvoie à des politiques ou à des faits
d'évolution du mix électrique en
introduction je tiens à vous dire que
ces études n'ont jamais un caractère
prescriptif que RTE a la mission légale
d'effectuer ses études et de leur en la
République mais que bien évidemment nous
ne pouvons pas nous opposer
à l'ouverture ou à la fermeture d'un
moyen de production et je sais Monsieur
le Député qu'on en parlera alors je me
suis permis de vous refaire une petite
histoire de ces de ces bilans
prévisionnels parce que ces études
prospectives on les appelle bilan
prévisionnel pour vous rendre compte de
la manière dont finalement c'est bilans
prévisionnel dans leur contenu se sont
enrichis au fil des années
les premiers bilans prévisionnels ont
été réalisés par l'entrée par
l'entreprise au début des années 2000 au
début à une époque où il y avait aucun
problème de sécurité d'approvisionnement
donc d'une certaine manière on a on
pourrait dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
sujets et ça a duré de nombreuses années
jusqu'à un peu avant 2010 et je dirais
jusqu'à 2013 2014 où là on a commencé à
constater que la question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de haie devenait une
question alors pourquoi à cette époque
je dirais un peu avant 2010 et jusqu'à
2013-2014 pourquoi donc à l'époque la
question de la sécurité la pro devient
une question déjà parce que la pointe en
France à 19h elle augmente je vous
rappelle que le raccorde le record de
France de la consommation d'un pointe à
19h c'est en février 2012 et nous avons
atteint 102 go
probablement un record qui serait
difficile à battre en même temps pendant
ces années nous savions que les moyens
thermiques français fuel et charbon
allait commencer à fermer non pas du
fait d'une décision gouvernementale
française mais du fait d'une application
des normes européennes qui ont conduit
les opérateurs à ne pas prolonger la
durée de vie d'un syndrome de tranches
au fioul et au charbon
et que
au début des années 2000 nous commençons
à voir des centrales thermiques
au gaz se poser la question de se mettre
sous cocon du fait des prix de
l'électricité bas j'en profite pour dire
que cette mise sous cocon
des centrales à gaz ont donné lieu aux
mécanismes de capacité mécanismes de
capacité sur lequel RT va commencer à
travailler en 2010 pour sa mise en
oeuvre en 2016 et ça ça fait partie de
ce que RTE a conçu pour garantir la
sécurité
d'approvisionnement bref
à l'époque la question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement comment ça se poser
non pas que ça pose un problème mais en
tout cas on commence à plus en parler à
davantage en parler et les bilans
prisonniers de RTE se concentrent à
l'époque essentiellement sur ces enjeux
des moyens thermiques fermeture charbon
progressive et
maintient voir développement du gaz
au même moment et à partir de 2012 tous
nos billets emprisonnaient évoquent la
fermeture potentielle de Fessenheim
parce que c'était un engagement de
campagne du président de la République
nouvellement alu ainsi que de la
majorité qui siège dans cette assemblée
[Musique]
à l'époque et pendant assez longtemps la
fermeture de Fessenheim n'est pas
considérée comme une question
puisqu'elle est corrélée à l'ouverture
de Flamanville 3 Flamanville 3 c'est le
Pr et no bilan prévisionnel successifs
évoque cette question
dans le bilan prévisionnel 2015 ensuite
de 2018 dans celui de 2019 et c'est le
bilan prévisionnel de 2019 qui prend
acte de la décorrélation entre la
fermeture de Fessenheim et
l'ouverture de l'EPR à Flamanville
Flamanville 3
donc je vous ai dit première phase
pendant assez longtemps de nombreuses
années pendant lequel les bilans
fusionnel part de sécurité d'après mais
la France n'a aucune question de
sécurité d'appro
premier changement au virage des années
2010 du fait de la fermeture des moyens
thermiques et des enjeux pour le gaz où
on commence à en discuter et dans cette
deuxième phase aussi nous évoquons
régulièrement la question de la
fermeture de Fessenheim parce qu'on a
bien entendu que c'était un engagement
de campagne du président de la
République et de la majorité
troisième phase
no bilan prévisionnel évolue à travers
celui de 2017
et à son ex évoluent pour englober tous
les aspects du mix électrique et c'est
ce bilan
prévisionnel 2017 qui entame le
mouvement alors qu'est-ce qu'il dit à
cette époque du point de vue de la
production
à cette époque il est clair pour toutes
les parties prenantes qu'il faut faire
une étude approfondie sur les camps et
séquences de la loi qui a été votée en
2015 et qui a été sanctionné par une
première PP en 2016 et donc c'est bien
prévisionnel 2017 qui finalement tire
les trajectoires
est-ce qu'ici à la fois dans la loi et
dans la TPE de 2016 même si la PP de
2016 ne contient pas toutes les
orientations notamment donc en matière
de nucléaire et ce bilan prévisionnel de
2017 il contient donc un grand nombre de
messages qui pour la plupart d'entre eux
ont pas pris beaucoup de rides monsieur
le président
sur le coup sur le court terme ce bilan
prévisionnel il explique qu'on ne peut
pas fermer donc sur le court terme pour
nous en 2017 c'est 2022 donc c'est 5 ans
plus tard on explique qu'on ne peut pas
fermer les dernières centrales au
charbon et en même temps commencer à
fermer des réacteurs nucléaires
dans un temps court
à moyen terme c'est-à-dire l'horizon
2025 il y a second choix à faire par les
pouvoirs publics qui est de réduire les
émissions de CO2 du secteur électrique
d'une part où commencer à fermer des
réacteurs nucléaires pour atteindre
l'objectif des 50% d'autre part ça c'est
le deuxième enseignement de moyen terme
et puis ce bilan prévisionnel 2017 il
conduit à plus long terme
échéance 2030 2035 à dire que les
scénarios à 50% de nucléaires peuvent
être atteints en 2030 et en 2035 sous
certaines conditions voilà quelques-unes
des conclusions je vous en livre
d'autres rapidement
ce document il chiffre des scénarios
différenciés d'orientation du mix
électrique et il conclut le moins
coûteux et celui qui prolonge la durée
de vie du plus grand nombre de central
la production nucléaire continuera
d'être compétitive en France et en
Europe malgré l'essor des renouvelables
et enfin dernière conclusion de ce bilan
prévisionnel 2017 qui pour nous est un
bilan charnière parce qu'il a éclairé
finalement la suite des opérations le
bilan prévisionnel 2017 et le premier
document prospectif qui intègre la
baisse de la disponibilité il émet des
ce moment un message d'alerte sur les
marges du système électrique notamment
donc en localisant certaines années
sensibles dans lesquelles nous sommes en
train de
rentrer voilà pour ce que nous avions
dit à l'époque dans les grands traits
lors de ce la publication de ce bilan
prévisionnel 2017 alors il a pas parlé
que de production il a parlé de
consommation
et à l'époque ce bilan était fondé sur
des hypothèses de consommation
qui était pas du tout celle
d'aujourd'hui en tout cas pas du tout
sur le long terme
et je vais vous dire pourquoi
[Musique]
en 2017 ça fait 7 ans que la
consommation française est flatte et
elle était même un peu de décroissante
à l'époque on constate que les
perspectives de croissance économique
sont en baisse on a vécu plusieurs
années d'espoir de relance à la suite de
la crise de 2008
les pouvoirs publics successifs ont pris
des mesures de relance de l'économie
française force et de constater que la
France est dans un monde de croissance
plutôt basse et que bien évidemment tout
ça ça a un drive sur sur les
perspectives de consommation en 2017 et
c'était le cas quelques années avant on
est dans le monde de la réglementation
thermique 2012 et je ne sais pas si vous
en avez parlé lors de des auditions mais
je veux m'arrêter deux secondes
là-dessus parce que c'est un élément qui
est très structurant la réglement la
réglementaire la réglementation
thermique 2012 pardon des bâtiments
c'est une norme qui développe la
maîtrise de la consommation donc qui
suppose qu'on va consommer moins
d'énergie globalement mais qui est une
norme très gaziaire et qui incite à
mettre du gaz dans les logements neufs
plutôt que de l'électricité et c'est un
paramètre très structurant quand on sait
que le parc de logement tire la
consommation d'électricité notamment
l'hiver à l'époque un symptôme de
directive européenne sortent notamment
sur sur l'éco-conception la politique
publique
de véhicules électriques et promise mais
pas encore mise en oeuvre nous n'avons
pas encore de politique hydrogène comme
aujourd'hui portée par un gouvernement
et surtout nous sommes dans le monde du
nous sommes encore dans le monde du
Facteur 4 le facteur 4 ce n'était pas la
neutralité carbone c'était divisé par 4
nos émissions d'ici 2050 et ça ça change
quand même beaucoup de choses sur la
question de l'électrification des
usages voilà le contexte dans lequel
nous avons discuté de la consommation
dans le dans le bilan prévisionnel 2017
un certain nombre de paramètres de ces
paramètres ont changé aujourd'hui
notamment la RE20 qui s'est substituée à
la réglementaire
à la réglementation thermique 2012 bien
évidemment la déclinaison de l'accord de
Paris dans la stratégie nationale bas
carbone qui remplace les perspectives du
Facteur 4 vont jouer un rôle absolument
déterminant je peux dire sans être
polémique que ces trajectoires de conso
en 2017 sont à peu près
au milieu des trajectoires de conso
portés par tel ou tel institution
notamment plus basse que celle
revendiquée par EDF mais plus haute que
celle étudiée par l'ADEME
puisque je sais que Jean-Bernard Lévy
vous a évoqué cette question de la
trajectoire de consommation hier
monsieur le Président dans son audition
ça c'était la troisième phase et c'est
probablement un premier virage de nos
bilans prévisionnels et puis je vous
rassure il y a que cinq phases et puis
je vais finir très vite
j'ai fini sur la console en disant qu'il
nous a pas échappé que la question des
trajectoires de consommation de la
France avait été un sujet non pas
polémique mais en couple en tout cas de
discussion qui n'avaient pas fait
consensus au moment de notre publication
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
lancé à partir de 2018 trois gros
travaux prospectifs qui eux étaient
thématiques et qui ont porté sur la
consommation ils ont été publiés entre
2019 et 2020 vous les trouvez sur notre
site internet une première étude sur la
production et sur le développement de
l'hydrogène en France une deuxième étude
sur le le déploiement des véhicules
électriques et leurs conséquence sur le
système électrique et enfin une
troisième étude sur les bâtiments et le
chauffage
qui était trois vecteurs et qui sont
finalement trois drivers
de ce que peut être la consommation
de la France demain bien évidemment le
but c'était de documenter plus finement
les trajectoires de consommation dans un
nouveau contexte de neutralité carbone
parce que ces études là elles intègrent
la déclinaison des accords de Paris ça
c'est la partie consommation de cette
phase 4 en même temps nous entamons une
étude avec l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie
qui nous permet de faire un zoom précis
sur des conditions
qui permettrait à un pays comme la
France
de piloter un système électrique avec
une autre part d'énergie renouvelable
dans son mixte production haute part
d'énergie
donc d'énergie renouvelable dans son mix
de production c'est
environ de 70 à 80 %
de ce point de vue là cette étude cette
brique de cette phase 4 elle a tiré 4
enseignements 4 conditions j'insiste qui
sont strictes et cumulatives pour
pouvoir piloter un mixer électrique avec
70 à 80% de NR dedans 1 il faudra
compenser la variabilité de production
par des moyens de flexibilité qui sont
adaptés c'est possible mais il faut les
dimensions pour
deuxième conclusion il faudra
reconfigurer les réseaux à la fois de
transport et de distribution contenu de
la charge du changement de la
morphologie de l'appareil de de
production troisième conclusion il
faudra qu'on assure la stabilité du
système et notamment le maintien de la
fréquence
en trouvant des substitutifs à la
disparition de certaines machines
tournantes vous savez que c'est des
alternateurs dans des machines
tournantes que ce soit sur le parc
thermique ou sur le parc de production
nucléaire qui assure un maintien de la
fréquence à 50 Hertz il y a des
solutions dont certaines sont courts de
développement notamment
les dispositifs d'électronique de
puissance et le Grit de forming sur
lequel nous ne sommes pas le seul tiesso
à travailler et enfin la quatrième
condition à ce qu'une telle politique
publique puisse être mise en place était
de faire évoluer les réserves
opérationnelles alors qu'est-ce que
c'est que les réserves opérationnelles
c'est les réserves dont disposé RTE pour
gérer les petits écarts d'équilibre
offre demande qui peuvent se traduire
par des écarts de fréquence nous avons à
notre disposition des réserves qu'on
peut appeler deux en quelques secondes à
en quelques minutes pour gérer les
écarts en temps réel ben en fait les
réserves opérationnelles c'est ça et
donc nous disons avec l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie j'insiste
que nous avons besoin nous aurions
besoin si d'aventure la France décidait
de s'orienter dans cette direction de
faire évoluer et de faire grandir ses
réserves opérationnelles qui protègent
finalement contre l'aléa de court terme
des énergies renouvelables donc ça
c'était la phase 4 une grande phase
préparatoire trois études thématiques
sur la consommation une étude thématique
sur la question du mix électrique tout
ça finissant synthétiser dans une phase
5 qui est notre étude future énergétique
qui est là qui est une grosse étude qui
fait mille pages qui elle se projette à
2050 donc 2050 c'est notre objectif
national de 0 carbone net et de et pas 0
émissions brute j'insiste
de ce point de vue là
futur énergétique de 1050 à le même ADN
que toutes nos toutes nos autres bilans
prévisionnels il est fondé sur la
garantie de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique de la
France
c'est notre travail c'est et c'est comme
ça qu'on produit nos études
à chaque fois qu'on en publie une et par
ailleurs il étudie que des mix
électrique et que des trajectoires qui
garantissent la neutralité carbone de la
France en 2050 puisque c'était la
question comme les autres ce rapport
projectif c'est fondé sur une très
longue concertation avec les parties
prenantes publication des données
systématiques comme d'habitude cette
étude modélise le système énergétique et
le système électrique français mais
aussi de 17 pays européens nous
modélisons la plaque européenne pour
simuler le fonctionnement du système
électrique pour vous donner donc une
idée nous simulons le fonctionnement du
système électrique à chaque heure de
chaque jour de chaque année pendant 30
ans
et on croise ces simulations avec
énormément de chroniques météo parce que
bien évidemment on intègre tout un tas
de paramètres et ces paramètres c'est
notamment la météo qui vous le savez
joue sur la consommation d'une part mais
il joue demain sur la production puisque
un certain nombre d'énergie
renouvelables dépend de la météo donc
c'est un très gros modèle et c'est des
calculs
assez considérable pour finir
les scénarios de consommation il y en a
trois essentiels et scénarios de mix de
production ont été issues de la
concertation concernant les mixes de
production d'électricité il représente
l'essentiel des avis qu'on a constaté à
l'époque c'est-à-dire plutôt en
2019-2020 dans la société française des
scénarios qui comportent du nouveau
nucléaire y compris beaucoup et des
scénarios qui tendent vers 100%
renouvelable les scénarios de conso
aussi dans le futur énergétique 2050
sont assez contrastées et peuvent
conduire enfin simule des chemins dans
lesquels la
société française ferait telle ou tel
choix de consommation donc dans le futur
énergétique on a vraiment fait un
un effort pour ouvrir les variantes et
essayer de couvrir le plus grand nombre
de chemins possibles
je dois dire que toutes ces trajectoires
elles garantissent la sécurité
d'approvisionnement nous tout ce qu'on a
écrit dans le futur énergétique sont des
chemins possibles pour le futur
électrique de la France cette étude nous
a permis de définir des volumes de
production des volumes de conso des
volumes de flexibilité nous avons nous
avons pu établir des coûts complets de
ce système électrique son empreinte
environnementale y compris son empreinte
CO2 tous ces chemins sont possibles ils
sont tous difficiles et on aura un
problème probablement qui seront plus
plus difficiles que d'autres mais à
bénicio il garantissent la sécurité
d'appro et à ce titre et parce que je
vous ai dit que
c'est bilans prévisionnel avaient évolué
et qu'un déroule de RTE une des missions
légales étaient de pouvoir éclairer le
débat et la décision publique c'est ce
qui a conduit le président de la
République
a notamment sur ces orientations de
futur énergétiques 2050 à opter en tout
cas à prendre des orientations qui
monsieur le député devrait trouver leur
traduction
sous le contrôle de votre vote dans une
future loi puisque ces questions de mix
énergétiques relèveront de cette
Assemblée nationale et du Sénat j'en ai
fini merci de m'avoir écouté
merci bien monsieur le Président pour ce
propos liminaire déjà très complet qui
nous permet de constater que les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête sont
largement scrutés à minima par le milieu
énergétique français
j'aurais une première question
sur votre perception de la compréhension
de vos
études bilan prévisionnel ou
l'étude futur énergétique par le grand
public comment est-ce que vous percevez
la perception de vos travaux et
l'adéquation de cette perception de vos
travaux par le par le grand public
je dirais que les choses ont évolué avec
le temps
avec le temps monsieur le Président
jusqu'au début des années 2000 et même à
la moitié des années 2000 les bilans
prévisionnels de RTE restaient assez
confidentiels mais aussi parce que la
question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement on était finalement
pas un enjeu
les choses ont changé à partir du bilan
prévisionnel 2017 alors honnêtement le
bilan préalable 2017 a pas été un objet
de communication grand public mais c'est
devenu d'une certaine manière un rapport
structurant parce que au-delà des
conclusions qu'il a rendu et que je vous
ai résumé tout à l'heure c'est sur la
base de ce rapport que
le gouvernement de l'époque et que
l'assemblée a décalé
la date de 50% de nucléaires de 2025 à
2035 c'est à la suite de ce bilan
prévisionnel et c'est aussi ce bilan
prisonnier qui a aidé à ce que le
gouvernement produise une nouvelle PPE
donc honnêtement à l'époque pas d'impact
au grand public mais enfin ça commence à
être une forme de préalable et d'input
et de donner d'entrée à certaines
orientations publiques alors
il est vrai que les choses ont changé
avec futur énergétique 2050
[Musique]
je crois que le fait que futur
énergétique 2050 je ne sais pas s'il est
vraiment un objet grand public
monsieur le Président parce que le monde
de l'électricité reste un monde complexe
dans lequel il est il est de bon ton de
maîtriser quelques unités de mesure nous
avons fait un énorme effort pour rendre
ces études intelligibles et pour faire
de la pédagogie parce qu'il nous
importait que que le débat ait lieu
parce que je crois que ces questions de
mix électrique sont un débat de société
sont un débat politique au sens noble du
terme
XC et qu'il était important que d'abord
la représentation nationale que vous
êtes les pouvoirs publics l'exécutif et
de manière générale les Français soient
informés des enjeux en matière de
transformation du mix électrique donc on
a fait un effort de pédagogie et puis il
faut aussi reconnaître que nous l'avons
publié un moment où la question
d'énergie
devenait une question plus prégnante que
qu'il y a 20 ans
si je peux me permettre je souvenez-vous
lors des élections locales en France il
y a 20 ans on parlait pas tellement
d'énergie
et même dans les élections nationales on
parlait pas tellement d'énergie en fait
c'était pas un sujet
le cumul des engagements de la France en
matière d'énergie renouvelable
nous engagements climatiques
les difficultés que rencontrent le parc
nucléaire aujourd'hui rendent la
question de l'énergie de l'électricité
un sujet grand public et donc je pense
que le côté populaire de futures
énergétiques et donc la manière dont sa
structuré le débat c'est la conjonction
de la qualité si je peux me permettre
c'est du gros travail qu'on a fait qu'on
a essayé de rendre pédagogique et aussi
du fait que les questions d'énergie
deviennent une question structurante
dans la manière dont on projette la
société française demain donc c'est la
rencontre de ces deux choses
et du coup dans cette attention
croissante du grand public pour pour les
sujets énergétiques dans leur ensemble
et vos travaux en particulier est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que
au-delà de l'attention sur sur le
rapport leur contenu et notamment leur
subtilité au-delà de la note de
présentation sont bien compris je pense
par exemple à la façon dont la
faisabilité du scénario 100% ENR
est perçu par le grand public est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que que vous
cherchez à mesurer à quoi vous êtes
attentif ou finalement une fois que le
rapport est parti et que la note de
synthèse l'accompagne bon bah ça fera sa
vie sans plus d'attention que cela
est difficile
donc RTE a vocation a publié une les
meilleurs rapports possibles et les plus
éclairants possible notre vocation ne va
pas jusqu'à ce qu'on garantisse monsieur
le député que chaque Français a bien
compris tous les enjeux de l'ensemble de
nos études qui je le rappelle sont
d'abord des études savantes qui sont
fondées sur de la concertation avec des
études des principes de transparence
une approche hypothétique au déductive
scientifique
de ce que nous faisons donc la question
que vous posez c'est est-ce qu'une
publication de nature scientifique ou
savante à vocation à être comprise
jusqu'au bout du grand public
probablement pas mais ces grandes leçons
et c'est pour ça que nous avions tiré 18
enseignements que j'espère les plus
compréhensibles possible eux peuvent
diffuser jusqu'au bout alors est-ce que
le grand public est-ce que le grand
public a compris que les différents mix
électriques
posèrent les différents mixes
électriques à échéance de 2050 pouvait
poser
des difficultés
les mix qui tendent vers 100%
renouvelable et la question de
l'acceptabilité
tous les mixs électriques qu'on a étudié
dans dans futures énergétique 2050 donc
il y en a 6 ils sont tous Je les dis
difficile à mettre en œuvre mais pour
des raisons différentes
il est évident que
les mix qui tendent vers 100%
renouvelable pose une question
d'insertion de cet appareil de
production dans le paysage français dans
les territoires français puis
d'insertion parce qu'on a démontré aussi
précisément que
c'était finalement pas tant une question
d'artificialisation
qu'une question d'insertion dans les
paysages mais c'est vrai que ça peut
poser des aussi des problèmes de
compatibilité avec l'usage du foncier
français je pense notamment à
l'agriculture
de ce point de vue là les mixs qui
tendent vers 100% renouvelable serait un
défi du point de vue de l'acceptabilité
comme il serait un défi technique du
point de vue du développement des
flexibilités dont on aurait besoin pour
compenser la variabilité comme les
questions de maintien de la fréquence et
de grille de forming donc de disparition
des machines tournantes sera pour nous
un défi
mais il n'en reste pas moins que il y a
d'autres scénarios dans lesquels on a
prévu du nouveau nucléaire qui reste un
défi parce qu'on ne peut pas dire que
construire 14 tranches de PR qui
fonctionnent en 2050 qui sont couplés
donc qui ont passé les phases d'essai
qui fonctionnent tout en 2050 n'est pas
un défi
on ne peut pas dire que le fait que la
France s'équipe de 4 gigawatts de SMS en
2050 qui fonctionne ne soit pas un défi
et on ne peut pas dire que prolonger 8
gigawatts de tranches nucléaire de
seconde génération au-delà de 60 ans ne
soit pas un défi vous avez reçu je crois
mon collègue Bernard dorozuk et je pense
qu'il a été prudent je n'ai pas écouté
son audition pardon mais
vous l'avez pas reçu pas encore bon
alors de toute façon je il mettra qu'il
ne soit pas prudent sur la capacité de
la SN à dire oui à des prolongations
au-delà de 5 ans de voir au-delà de 60
ans donc tout est un défi simplement les
mixes électriques qu'on a projeté ils
sont tous difficiles mais ils sont pas
tous difficiles pour les mêmes raisons
des fois c'est plus une question de défi
technologique de défis industriels de
capacité à faire de capacité de la
filière de l'autre il y a peut-être
davantage des enjeux fonciers
d'implantation territoriale et
d'acceptabilité il ne nous revient pas à
nous de trancher sur ce qui est plus dur
ou pas plus dur
parce que je le répète et c'est ma
conviction personnelle ces questions
d'énergie et ces questions d'électricité
ce qui revient au même parce que dans un
monde décarboné c'est l'électricité qui
est l'énergie dominante donc en fait
cette question de comment va
vers la neutralité carbone et par quel
moyen on va produire notre électricité
décarbonée demain c'est un choix de
société que nous on veut bien éclairer
mais qui revient à la sagesse de cet
assemblée de tranchée parce que
c'est une question de mode de vie du
peuple français demain
merci
du coup je reformule un tout petit peu
autrement dire vous avez vous-même
indiqué que vos rapports font autorité
dans le débat public et sont de plus en
plus
des objets qui deviennent politiques
puisque grand public a accès directement
ce n'est plus seulement un outil de
construction de la proposition politique
ou technique d'ailleurs mais bien devenu
un outil de justification du choix
politique enfin en quelque sorte est-ce
que du coup vous êtes attentif
à la à la mauvaise interprétation par
certains acteurs de certains de vos
écrits à la
communication que ce soit dans les
médias dans le débat public des études
partielles partielles sans sans qu'elle
soit complètement équilibrée je pense à
une précédente ministre de l'énergie qui
au moment de la sortie de de votre étude
dit super vous voyez RTE dit on peut
faire du 100% renouvelable il y a pas de
souci on va y aller
c'est un peu raccourci par rapport à ce
que vous venez de nous expliquer par
rapport à la complexité que vous venez
nous présenter est-ce que RTE laisse
faire n'importe quoi de la mise en forme
dans le débat public de ses études
à écouter
l'expression
l'expression des Français et a fortiori
les ministres et libres et RTE d'une
certaine manière à pas beaucoup de
moyens de contrôler l'expression à la
fois des Français qui est libre dans ce
pays et des ministres qui est libre
également et je pense qu'on peut s'en
féliciter donc nous nous faisons la
meilleure communication et et la
meilleure pédagogie possible après dans
ce pays la parole est libre il y a des
controverses sur nos travaux c'est
heureux qu'il y ait des controverses dès
lors que ces controverses sont
scientifiques
c'est à dire que
moi j'ai toujours appelé à ce que
si certaines institutions n'étaient pas
d'accord avec ce que nous produisions
nous organisons une controverse à un
grand C au sens noble du terme et qu'on
se parle de scientifique à scientifique
c'est-à-dire que si quelqu'un une
institution
considère que nous avons fait une
mauvaise interprétation d'accord
discutons-en mais discutons-en
publiquement
et discutons-en donner contredonnée et
interprétation contre contre
interprétation
et moi qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y a
un symptôme de personnes qui ont dit
qu'il n'était pas d'accord avec nos
études mais je n'ai pas vu de
contre-expertise de la profondeur de ce
que nous avons produit pour démontrer
que nous nous étions trompé voilà alors
le problème c'est que la controverse
scientifique ça demande beaucoup de
travail ça demande de l'expertise et de
l'abnégation et que on peut pas
organiser une controverse en 180 signes
sur Twitter là effectivement j'en
conviens monsieur le Président si on
organise ces controvers sur Twitter je
vous confirme qu'on ne s'en sortira pas
j'ajoute et que il me semble que notre
étude future énergétique a quand même
largement dépolarisé le débat et moi
donc il me semble qu'il a assez
largement apaisé
disons que les Français se jettent un
peu moins d'éoliennes et de tranches
nucléaires à la figure et de ce point de
vue là je suis satisfait que on arrive
contribué à ce que ce débat sur
l'électricité de demain soit un débat
plus documenté plus responsable et plus
apaisé
est-ce que du coup vous suggérez
qu'avant cette étude
les décisions énergétiques ou le débat
énergétique était pas assez documenté
je sais pas si je sais pas s'il y a une
limite à la documentation
on peut pas c'est la première fois qu'on
se projetait à la neutralité
de 2050
et je trouve plutôt bien que la France
est réussie à se projeter avec une étude
complète dans cette perspective de 0
carbone net en 2050 on est probablement
le seul pays européen à avoir fait ce
type de travail aussi profond et aussi
complet pour éclairer les futurs
politiques publiques françaises après
les politiques publiques elles sont
proposées et structurer par l'exécutif
elles sont votées par par cette
assemblée de ce point de vue monsieur le
député ça m'échappe assez largement
alors c'est là que je n'arrive pas
totalement à suivre le raisonnement
mais encore une fois je n'ai pas une
compréhension aussi précise que que vous
du sujet
vous nous dites finalement c'est qu'à
partir de 2017 qu'on commence à
réfléchir à
la question de 0 carbone la trajectoire
carbone de 2050 0 carbone net pour la
France
cette
objectif
de 0 carbone net il date formellement
formellement de la cop21 Paris
qui formalisent un petit peu cet
objectif pour la France 2015 c'est aussi
l'année de l'adoption de la tête CV
de façon à peu près concomitante avec la
COP 21
j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal à
imaginer
qu'au moment de se débat là on n'est pas
un minimum préparer les objectifs
d'où viennent à ce moment-là les
objectifs proposés et obtenus par la
France au moment de la cop21 en matière
de décarbonation si avant cette date
personne n'avait réfléchi à ça c'est
quand même ce que vous suggérez
dans vos propos donc d'où viennent ces
objectifs de décarbonation si avant la
cop21 on y avait pas réfléchi
alors non je n'ai pas dit ça monsieur le
député et les engagements de la France à
la COP 21 sont des engagements déjà de
limiter le
réchauffement climatique à un gabarit
autour de degrés qui correspond pour
être précis à un scénario du GIEC qui
s'appelle le RCP 4.5 et ceux qui sont
inférieurs et qui conduisent à définir
des trajectoires d'émissions carbone des
différents pays
la France n'est pas allée négocier au
sein de la COP 21 sa trajectoire de mix
de production d'électricité on a pris
des objectifs de résultats on s'est
engagé à limiter le réchauffement
climatique sur la terre et c'est heureux
voilà
je ne crois pas que la France aurait
besoin d'être équipé pour signer
l'accord de Paris de se poser la
question de savoir si il fallait faire
plus ou moins 10% de nouveaux nucléaires
ou plus ou moins 10% des éoliennes
offshore
ce n'était pas le sujet en revanche on
peut constater que la loi de 2015 la
ltecv dans un de ces titres elle prévoit
des outils de pilotage des questions
climatiques et des questions d'énergie
c'est écrit
d'une part que parmi ces outils de
pilotage elle crée la stratégie
nationale bas carbone là SNBC qui bien
évidemment puisque la loi est votée en
2015 a vocation a décliner les
engagements que la France a pris
lors de la COP 21 mais c'est pas que les
engagements directs que la France a pris
lors de la COP 21 c'est je vous signale
que l'Union européenne avait depuis
longtemps des objectifs de baisse de ses
émissions carbone que la France avait
voté et à laquelle elles adhéraient donc
dans l'ordre des facteurs il y a eu
les accords de Paris qui parle du
réchauffement climatique
un texte de loi
voté par cette assemblée qui prévoyait
un certain nombre d'instruments de
pilotage dont la stratégie nationale bas
carbone qui était un document qui allait
décliner le comment fait-on
quels sont les grands paramètres qu'il
faut que la France mette en œuvre dans
le cadre européen et dans le cadre de la
cop21 c'est comme ça que ça c'est fait
et donc le bilan prévisionnel de 2017 il
est venu tirer les conclusions de ces
nouvelles orientations de politiques
publiques parce que la stratégie
nationale va carbone c'est une
orientation de politique publique c'est
c'est pas RTE qui construit les
orientations de politiques publiques sur
la consommation nous nous prenons acte
des politiques publiques qui sont
décidées et votés dans dans ces
assemblées et nous en tirons des
trajectoires et nous discutons autour de
la question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement ensuite
c'est intéressant parce que du coup vous
venez un peu de nuancer quand même ce
que vous avez vous-même dit ce qu'a dit
votre prédécesseur quant au moment où la
préoccupation de la décarbonation
arrive vraiment à toucher la
construction du système électrique
c'est-à-dire que
prétendez quand même vous votre
prédécesseur que
il y a eu des changements après 2017 à
partir de 2019 plutôt sur la conception
qu'on a de la construction du réseau
électrique parce que avant on ne
réfléchissait pas à l'impact de la
décarbonation ou pas de la même façon
alors que finalement vous ne nous
démontrer que la décarbonation c'est un
sujet qui est présent dans le débat
public et dans les préoccupations des
décideurs publics bien avant 2017 et que
donc peut-être qu'un certain nombre
d'études en 2015
ou de choix politiques documentés en
ne prennent pas correctement en compte
ce qui est déjà largement présent dans
le débat public et parfois même affirmé
par ce la même qui qui porte le débat
public
d'où parce que bon j'en viens du coup à
cette période de 2015 pendant laquelle
vous vous exerciez des mines
responsabilités soit de conseiller en
charge de l'énergie auprès du Premier
ministre jusqu'en 2014 soit de
conseiller sur l'énergie du président de
la République jusqu'en 2015 comment est
construite
comment sont construits les scénarios de
la loi tpcv
comment est construit l'étude d'impact
et pourquoi tous les éléments que nous
venons de voir aujourd'hui que vous vous
démontrez comme scientifique qui sont
largement documentés dans les rapports
de RTL ne sont pas présents dans l'étude
d'impact de la loi epcv qui est quand
même celle qui fixe notamment pour
objectif de ramener à 50% la part du
nucléaire à l'horizon 2025 et qui se
traduit comme première effet sur notre
système électrique d'avoir
comme priorité le remplacement d'une
énergie décarbonée par les énergies
renouvelables alors que la priorité
aurait vraisemblablement dû être pour la
décarbonation qui était donc déjà
largement présente en 2015 c'est ce que
vous venez de dire comme préoccupation
publique de remplacer les moyens de
production d'électricité carbonée par
des énergies renouvelables non carbonées
bon
vous vous me posez deux questions assez
différentes la première c'est que
la décarbonation du pays sous le régime
du Facteur 4 et la décarbonation du pays
sous le régime de la du 0.9 carbone 2050
c'est pas pareil et c'est pas du tout
pareil
c'est pas du tout pareil parce qu'en
fait le facteur 4 disposait qu'on avait
divisé par 4 et qu'on allait pas
supprimer nos émissions CO2 net et donc
dans un monde où on est où on promet le
facteur 4 il reste de la consommation
d'énergie fossile à terme notamment le
gaz qui pendant très longtemps et encore
récemment vous l'avez vu à l'occasion
des débats européens sur la taxonomie
était considéré même si c'était une
énergie fossile comme une énergie de
transition et c'est vrai que c'est une
c'est une énergie qui lorsqu'on utilise
pour produire de l'électricité et mais
substantiellement moins que le fioul est
que le charbon substantiellement donc
quand vous dites on parlait déjà de
décarbonation avant 2015 oui mais on
parlait pas de la même décarbonation et
pas du même effort et il n'y a il n'est
pas discutable que
un accord de Paris qui est qui est un
hardcore climatique et que ses
conséquences sur ce que ça veut dire sur
la production d'énergie en France et
notamment la production d'électricité
n'a pas du tout le même impact sur la
manière dont on forme le mix et surtout
n'a pas le même impact sur la
consommation
puisque il y a tu il y a une grande
différence entre être zéro net en 2050
ou garder une part résiduelle
d'utilisation des fossiles c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs depuis
l'accord de Paris et sa déclinaison dans
la SNBC française les courbes
d'électrification des usages elle monte
mais c'est normal parce que l'effort à
faire pour aller combler ces dernières
volumes d'utilisation des fossiles
est assez
est assez important
alors vous avez donc évoqué mon rôle de
conseiller du Premier ministre
du mois de mai 2012 au 1er avril 2014
puisqu'effectivement j'ai été conseillé
du Premier ministre Jean-Marc Ayrault
qui à qui a succédé Emmanuel Valls au
premier avril
alors vous avez dit j'étais conseiller
je vous rappelle que le rôle d'un
conseiller c'est de coordonner l'action
de l'administration et de préparer les
arbitrages qui sont soumis au Premier
ministre
vous m'avez demandé si à l'époque il y
avait eu des études
préalable à la loi sur la transition
énergétique et la croissance verte il y
avait des données il y avait pas d'étude
de l'ampleur de futurs énergétiques de
mais ma foi c'est pas parce que futur
énergétique de 1050 et est une étude
qui permettra de mieux structurer le
débat et la décision publique de demain
en tout cas je l'espère qu'il faut se
plaindre que la France n'est pas pris un
certain nombre de virage
je vous rappelle que les lois Grenelle 1
et Grenelle 2 voté par ces assemblées
sont déjà des lois de transition
écologique et de transition énergétique
sans non plus qu'on se pose la question
de savoir si à l'époque il y avait une
étude de l'ampleur de futurs
énergétiques il y avait des bilans
prévisionnels
l'administration française et
l'Assemblée en faisait son miel parce
que tout ça est public donc il y a
toujours eu des données mis à
disposition c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue future énergétique ça marque une
rupture parce que c'est la première fois
que RTE présente une étude aussi
complète d'une part et surtout qui se
projette aussi loin puisque j'ai oublié
de le lire tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive à se projeter à 30 ans ce qui en
termes de prospective est un exercice
assez difficile mais je crois pas qu'on
puisse avoir un raisonnement récursoy
qui conduira à dire il aurait fallu
avoir des études de la qualité de future
énergétique 2050 pour voter la loi
lteccv sinon on peut faire le même
raisonnement pour l'ensemble des lois
qui ont considéré l'énergie Grenelle
Grenelle 2 loi Nome loi de 2000 etc
à chaque fois de l'histoire
les gouvernements français quel que soit
leur couleur et les assembler quel que
soit leur couleur ont voté des textes en
fonction des données scientifiques qui
étaient à disposition voilà
avec une différence majeure entre les
textes énergétiques hantée 2015 et ce de
2015 et poste 2015 c'est la première
fois qu'on fixe des limitations en
volume et en proportion de certains
moyens de production enfin en réalité
que d'un seul c'est d'ailleurs un des
sujets
que je n'ai pas encore réussi à éclairer
au fil des auditions que nous avons eu
ou en tout cas avec une réponse qui
semble objective c'est d'où viennent
d'où vient l'objectif des 50% de part de
nucléaire dans le mix électrique
français c'est-à-dire que la volonté
de faire évoluer ce mix je peux la
comprendre le législateur est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut mais pourquoi ces
50% et finalement comment c'est
construit comment ces documenté alors
qu'on voit que le premier effet qu'on
crée sur le terrain de ces 50 %, c'est
d'avoir remplacé une énergie décarbonée
par une autre énergie intermittente et
pas d'avoir substitué des énergies
fossiles à des énergies renouvelables
alors c'est la vous dites que c'est la
première fois qu'on limite en volume et
en proportion je
note que la loi
que la loi altecv 2015 elle elle fixe un
plafond de capacité à installer
nucléaire à
63,2 gigawatts ça ça doit être l'article
187 de ce texte les 50% de nucléaires à
l'horizon 2025 sont dans sont dans un
article qui n'est pas normatif chez lui
un résumé de l'intervention de mon
prédécesseur François brodt hier il a
répondu à cette question cet objectif de
50%
à l'horizon 2050 était une ambition
politique
n'est pas normatif le seul élément
normatif qui structure les politiques
publiques dans le texte c'est bien le
plafonnement de la capacité nucléaire
française à
63,2 gigawatts ce qui nous met pas ipso
facto à 50% de nucléaire comme vous le
pouvez le constater aujourd'hui
alors vous avez dit pourquoi comment
s'est construit les documenter écouter
je pense que vous avez donc auditionné
suffisamment de personnes qui qui
étaient là lorsque cet engagement
politique de campagne électorale a été a
été pris
simplement
demandons-nous quels sont les ressorts
de de cette idée de baisse de la part du
nucléaire de seconde génération dans le
mix français
en 2012
on est quelques mois donc après
Fukushima
Fukushima c'est un tremblement de terre
dans le monde du nucléaire sans mauvais
jeu de mots je vous rappelle qu'à la
suite de Fukushima le Japon congèle son
nucléaire je vous rappelle que la suite
de Fukushima les Allemands décident de
sortir du nucléaire de ce point de vue
la France et à ce moment là elle assume
de garder son nucléaire et de continuer
à faire son nucléaire parce que à ma
connaissance en tout cas depuis que je
fais de l'énergie je n'ai entendu aucune
majorité
de l'Assemblée nationale ni aucun
exécutif
en exercice dire qu'il voulait sortir du
nucléaire la France a jamais voulu dire
dire qu'elle voulait sortir du nucléaire
donc ça c'est un premier élément il y a
Fukushima et malgré Fukushima la France
je ne crois pas que quelqu'un ait eu
l'idée
en tout cas ce qui était au pouvoir de
vouloir sortir du du nucléaire quel que
soit
la majorité ou la coalition au pouvoir
en 2012-2013 2014 n'oubliez pas que les
consommations de la France sont à la
baisse et au mieux stables pourquoi
bah je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
il y a des politiques publiques
notamment de maîtrise de la consommation
qui tire le tertiaire et le résidentiel
à la baisse la mobilité donc électrique
ne s'est pas développé et à la vérité la
croissance économique est tombée à la
suite du choc de 2008-2009
le parc nucléaire à l'époque produit
beaucoup monsieur le Président
il produit beaucoup au point d'exporter
et en 2012 la France doit exporter 42
terawattheure par an de l'ordre de 45
2013 le même ordre de grandeur 2014 plus
de 60
sur une consommation France de 480W
et puis fondamentalement il y a une
ambition de diversification du mix
électrique
alors c'est pas au détriment du
nucléaire et au profit des ENR
contrairement à ce qu'on pense
c'est au détriment du nucléaire de
deuxième génération à date au détriment
d'autres énergies parce que il y a des
enjeux de résilience technologique vous
présidez une commission sur la
souveraineté la souveraineté elle
s'organise autour de la de la
souveraineté en termes donc
d'approvisionnement de combustible ou
est-ce qu'on achète du gaz et du Pétrole
et je rappelle que le premier enjeu de
la France c'est donc d'arrêter du donc
d'acheter du gaz et du pétrole à des
pays qui ne sont pas nos amis donc il
faut qu'on
s'électrifie vite il y a des questions
de souveraineté technologiques
maîtrisons les technologies qui sont
installées sur notre territoire avec nos
ingénieurs pour qu'on soit sûr de
maîtriser les process et il y a des
questions de résilience est-ce qu'on est
capable de résister à des chocs
type Ukraine mais des chocs aussi
techniques est-ce que un risque ne
mettrait pas la France a mal et sous ces
questions de proportion du nucléaire il
y a toujours ces questions de
diversification du mix
pour utiliser une expression populaire
je dirais
essayons de ne pas mettre tous nos œufs
dans le même panier
et à l'époque la question est bien
de se demander comment est-ce qu'on
multiplie les sources de production
d'électricité le nucléaire de seconde
génération est hyper dominant il peut
être exposé à un défaut génériques
techniques qui mettrait à la France dans
de grandes difficultés d'ailleurs je
dois le dire ce défaut est arrivé avec
la corrosion sous contrainte
on est à l'époque dans une grande
incertitude sur la capacité à prolonger
les tranches nucléaires françaises de
seconde génération parce qu'il y a eu
Fukushima et qu'il faut faire des
travaux d'adaptation et de sûreté poste
Fukushima qu'on a appelé le grand
carénage
et pendant ce temps là il y a toujours
eu un souhait que la France développe le
Pr donc on n'est pas dans un monde où on
a voulu
faire mal au nucléaire on est dans un
monde où on a voulu
diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement
en diversifiant nos technologies
nucléaires c'est-à-dire en lançant un
EPR
certes en faisant la baisser la
proportion de nucléaire de deuxième
génération parce que aussi d'une
certaine manière il nous expose un
risque technique la preuve en ce moment
la France a porté le Pr malheureusement
le perd n'est pas en service sur le sol
français mais la France n'a pas fait que
ça la France elle financière
la France a financé la street pendant
longtemps la France elle a financé six
géo la France elle finance le réacteur
de recherche médicale Jules robits
donc
la France a toujours eu une politique
nucléaire la question c'est comment
diversifions-nous les générations de
nucléaires et comment mélanger nous la
production d'énergie nucléaire avec la
production d'énergie renouvelable pour
qu'on gagne en résilience voilà quel
était monsieur le Président les grands
paramètres de l'époque qui du point de
vue de la résilience à la fois toute
énergie et contenues de la guerre en
Ukraine et de son impact sur le gaz et
contenu de ce qu'on rencontre sur la
corrosion sur contre aujourd'hui reste
une question absolument d'actualité
et ce qui est un raisonnement
intéressant puisque le problème
générique de la corrosion sous
contrainte d'aujourd'hui touche
finalement les réacteurs les plus
récents de notre parc et ce sont les
réacteurs les plus anciens de la
deuxième génération qui ne sont pas
touchés par ce problème et qui nous
permettent d'assurer pour passer l'hiver
la base ce qui signifie ce qui signifie
que finalement la question de
l'ancienneté des réacteurs de deuxième
génération et toute relative parce que
au sein des réacteurs de deuxième
génération et une forme de diversité
technologique qui fait que ce sont les
plus anciens qui assurent aujourd'hui le
passage de l'hiver
[Musique]
il y a une chose dans les propos que
entre votre propos liminaire et ce que
vous venez de dire qui me semble un peu
contradictoire on dit bon 2012 13 14
la consommation française est stable
néanmoins vous nous dites la pointe en
2013 et en 2014 a augmenté
donc comment comment est-ce qu'on traite
ça parce que d'accord la base est stable
la moyenne est stable les gigawh c'est
stable mais les gigawatts eux ça ça
augmente comment RTE prend ou lorsque
vous êtes dans vos dans vos précédentes
fonctions vous prenez ces éléments en
compte pour adapter adapter le réseau à
cette époque là
alors effectivement il faut faire une
différence entre ce que consomme la
France chaque année aujourd'hui la
France consomme 470 terawattheure par an
et notez que en 2000 en 2012 soit il y a
10 ans la France devait consommer 480W
sa consommation d'électricité pour le
moment
et effectivement on consomme même un peu
moins alors
soyons juste il y a il y a eu le covid
il y a eu des désordres économiques qui
ont fait que pendant quelques années la
France a légèrement ma
légèrement à consommer mais on est
vraiment dans les mêmes ordres de
grandeur cette année vu les efforts des
Français sur la sobriété nous je pense
que le bilan à la fin de l'année sera à
la baisse
il y a des points mais en fait les
pointes c'est des questions de
thermosensibilité c'est essentiellement
des questions de chauffage et
d'isolation voilà
d'ailleurs leur corps a été battu en
2012 mais la pointe elle augmente plus
depuis ce temps-là il est à pointe elle
a plutôt tendance à baisser
dans nos études prévisionnelles pour le
passage de l'hiver 2022 2023 on décide
qu'une pointe électrique à 19h pour un
hiver de très grand froid et au-dessus
de 90 GW peut-être 95 mais pas 102
donc on concilie ça donc le métier de
RTE au-delà de ses études prospectives
c'est de gérer le système électrique
donc on s'occupe de l'équilibre offre
demande et ça nous permet d'avoir une
vision prospective sur le volume de
moyens de production qui serait
souhaitable en France dans les qui
viennent pour garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et donc de respecter
le critère de trois heures et puis nous
mettons en place le pilotage en temps
réel qui permet donc effectivement de
passer la pointe et de garantir que la
France plus ces importations permettent
de couvrir une pointe à 19h maintenant
ce serait plus 102 maintenant ce serait
plutôt supérieur à 90
au cas d'espèce
[Musique]
c'est ça qui pose problème cet hiver
c'est pas ce que les Français consomment
en moyenne d'abord c'est d'abord la
problématique de passer le plateau du
matin et la pointe du soir mais c'est
deux choses assez différentes vous avez
monsieur le député pointé le fait que
vous avez raison de pointer le fait que
la corrosion sous contrainte
frappait plutôt les paliers récents que
le palier ancien 900 900 MW mais la
question de la maîtrise des risques et
de la résilience il faut qu'on se la
pose globalement ce n'est pas parce
qu'un défaut est apparu sur les tranches
les plus récentes de la seconde
génération qu'il ne faut pas penser la
question de la résilience française et
donc la question de la résidence
française c'est de faire une analyse de
risque et d'avoir des actions de
maîtrise de ce risque pour que la France
soit capable d'encaisser des chocs
techniques ou des mauvaises nouvelles
techniques et si l'aventure supporter
atteinte ce qu'elle soit capable de se
redresser le plus rapidement possible
de ce point de vue là la notion de
diversification technologique
au sein de la famille nucléaire mais
aussi entre le nucléaire et d'autres
sources de production d'énergie et
quelque chose d'absolument structurant
pour l'électricité
il ne reste pas moins que notre
principal problème aujourd'hui de
souveraineté de résilience c'est que la
France est un pays à 63% fossiles
et 63% de la consommation d'énergie
finale c'est du pétrole et du gaz c'est
du pétrole et du gaz que nous ne
produisons pas et c'est du pétrole et du
gaz que nous achetons à des pays qui ne
sont pas forcément nos alliés
géostratégiques et je crois que il faut
qu'on se pose d'abord cette question
sortons de cette dépendance gaz et
pétrole qui est aujourd'hui
ultra majoritaire dans ce que la France
consomme en énergie nous avons fait la
démonstration que l'électrification
était une voie pour gagner en
souveraineté parce que moi c'est
l'électricité qu'on produit sur le
territoire de l'Europe et donc
essentiellement de la France avec des
technologies qu'on maîtrise on sait
faire des énergies renouvelables on sait
faire du nucléaire mais au sein de ce
monde de l'électricité
et ont aussi la transparence de nous
poser la question de la résilience
comment peut-on passer des pics des
creux des chocs techniques et c'est là
où la question des différentes
générations de nucléaires jouent et
c'est là où la question du juste
équilibre entre du nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables joue et c'est
aussi la question de la diversification
des énergies renouvelables au sein de
cette même famille parce que toutes les
énergies renouvelables ne produisent pas
toutes pareilles et produisent pas
toutes de l'électricité au même moment
voilà
du coup j'aurais une dernière question
avant de passer la parole au rapporteur
vous nous dites dans votre propos
introductif et dans vos réponses
successives que la question de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement finalement
devient une problématique à partir des
années
2010 12 14 avant c'est pas trop c'est
pas trop un sujet
pourquoi du coup est-ce que la doctrine
des bilans prévisionnels de RTE puis
la doctrine légale change dans la mesure
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement en
2015 pour intégrer à partir de 2015 les
interconnexions qui jusque là ne
rentrait pas en compte dans la
définition de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
[Musique]
la question de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement elle se
pose pas elle se pose pas à travers
ça a toujours été l'objet des bilans
prévisionnels
et j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'en fait la
question de la sécurité d'appro en
électricité elle commence à se poser au
moment où les moyens thermiques ferment
la France a fermé plus de 12 plus de
plus de 12 on est passé de
oui on a dû fermer plus de 12 gigawatts
de moyen thermique
en quelques années je dis le 11 c'est
pas une politique du gouvernement je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est simplement
des normes européennes des seuils de
pollution des questions de grand
carénage des questions d'investissement
à faire qui fait que l'opérateur
essentiellement donc EDF a
progressivement fermé des moyens au
fioul et au charbon et vous savez qu'il
ne reste plus de centrale ou la part des
à part quelques turbines à combustion à
part des tags et qui servent pour
l'ultra-pointe et quelques et trois
tranches à charbon sur deux centrales à
Saint-Avold
et
accords de mai donc c'est à travers ça
que j'ai dit que la question commençait
à se poser parce que quand vous voyez
simplement des des moyens de production
fermée vous demandez quel effet ça c'est
une première chose deuxième chose
la France a fermé et pour me faire bien
comprendre la France a fermé les
opérateurs ont fermé ces moyens de
production à raison puisque la France a
déjà pris des engagements climatiques
européens pendant que l'ensemble de ce
qu'elle devait mettre en œuvre pour les
remplacer
cet ensemble a appris du retard à tous
les étages
la France est en retard sur le Pr qui
devait être en service en 2012 la France
est en retard sur les EnR terrestres la
France est en retard sur les roches
la France a même été en retard pour
mettre en service à centrale de
landivision en Bretagne
donc tout le monde conçoit que lorsque
progressivement des moyens thermiques
ferment dans des grandes proportions et
que tout ce que vous prévoyez en face
est en retard bah il est évident que
vous perdez les marges et c'est ça qui
s'est passé
on savait déjà au début des années 2010
que le parc nucléaire français au début
des années 20 nous y sommes
rencontreraient des périodes d'arrêt
plus longues puisque le fait qu'on sache
que le parc allait avoir 40 ans qui
aurait des Sénats longues et des gros
investissements qui allaient rendre à
disponible le parc
on le sait depuis longtemps en fait ça
fait 40 ans qu'on sait que le parc aura
40 ans et donc oui effectivement à cette
époque il y a une forme de conjonction
de de facteurs qui font baisser les
marges de la France et qui conduisent
progressivement à se poser la question
de la sécurité des approvisionnement
mais en 2012-2014 c'est pas un problème
parce qu'en 2012 2014 j'ai dit que la
France était très exportatrice en
matière d'électricité et c'était son
électricité nucléaire
quand je vous ai dit 42 gigawatts en
45 je me suis trompé c'était 47 en 2013
et 65 ans en 2014 on était encore très
exportateur
donc la fermeture des centrales
thermiques elle pose la question mais
elle dit mais on n'est pas encore que
c'est un problème on dit que ça peut le
devenir si on fait pas donc attention au
parc nucléaire à la manière dont on
développe le rythme des éoliennes etc
c'est ça qu'on a dit
peut-être un dernier mot sur le parc
nucléaire français parce que c'est
important
je veux bien qu'on parle du parc
nucléaire et vous dites des choses
intéressantes sur qu'est-ce que le père
devait remplacer par exemple ce qui
devait remplacer le thermique qui
s'éteint au courant des années 2010 ou
est-ce qu'il devait remplacer Fessenheim
tel que la loi finalement la écrit en
introduisant un plafonnement mais ma
question n'était pas celle-là
ma question était assez précise
en 2015 la doctrine dans les bilans
prévisionnels de RTE sur le calcul de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement change
cette doctrine elle change même un peu
avant 2015 de façon
plus subtile mais en 2015 ce changement
de doctrine est codifié dans le calcul
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement très
simple avant 2015 la sécurité
d'approvisionnement elle est calculée
net
d'importation enfin elle est calculée
brute à se dire avant importation et à
partir de 2015 on compte les capacités
d'interconnexion et d'approvisionnement
dans le calcul de de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement pourquoi ce
changement au moment où finalement cette
question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement devient une
préoccupation
je suis étonné je sais pas monsieur le
Président d'où vous tenez cette
information pour moi donc RTE alors je
n'y étais pas encore et j'étais loin d'y
être puisque donc en 2010 je faisais
autre chose
pour moi donc donc RTU intégré depuis
2010 les soldes d'import-export dans ses
études de sécurité d'appro et donc je
serai heureux de pouvoir répondre de
manière plus détaillée donc à votre
question mais je sais pas d'où vous
tenez cette information en tout cas
c'est pas la mienne c'est c'est pas
celle de de mon collègue
les études récentes qu'on fait sur
récente mais même depuis les années 2010
elles sont fondées sur un modèle qui
simule le système électrique et qui
simule les échanges et on simule les
échanges
mais en fait on simule pas les échanges
en solde importateur ou en soldat
importateur je vous ai dit qu'on
modélisait le système électrique à
chaque heure du jour et de la nuit
pendant l'ensemble de la durée de la
perspective donc on module les échanges
à chaque heure
et donc il est vrai et même si la France
a été très longtemps
exportatrice et que cette année elle
sera importatrice en solde de net
les échanges ça va jamais dans un seul
sens il y a des fois on exporte et des
fois où on apporte mais à ma
connaissance c'est depuis le début des
années 2010 qu'on intègre ces questions
ces questions d'importation et
d'exportation j'insiste dans la manière
dont on modélise le système électrique
et donc on modélise les échanges entre
les pays à chaque heure parce que c'est
ça qui rencontre de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement il subit il ne
suffit pas d'être exportateur en solde
net positif pour garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement des Français il faut
que les français d'électricité à chacun
du jour et de la nuit c'est ça l'enjeu
et c'est d'ailleurs d'abord ça l'enjeu
avant de savoir si on est exportateur
net global sur l'année même si c'est bon
pour le commerce extérieur
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président pour ses premières
ces premières réponses et ses premières
explications je repars aussi 2015
lorsque des années 2012-2014 lorsque
vous préparez au sein du gouvernement
enfin du cabinet du premier ministre la
loi 2015 j'imagine que vous avez des
échanges avec les administrations et
avec RTE sur l'impact d'une telle
trajectoire en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement est-ce que les
administrations et ou RTE émettent des
réserves ou des alertes sur le risque
éventuel que la trajectoire qui se
dessine pourrait faire courir sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement ou pas
bon déjà moi j'étais à Matignon j'ai
quitté matinion le 1er avril 2014 donc
c'est pas sous c'est pas dans mon rôle
de conseiller que la loi a été déposée
sur le bureau de l'Assemblée puisque je
crois qu'elle a été en juillet 2014 et
ni même qu'elle a été débattu
puisqu'elle a été battue entre septembre
2014 et voter à l'été 2015
cela dit je ne peux pas dire que je n'ai
pas au courant de cette engagement
politique
monsieur le rapporteur je
suis ennuyé par par d'autres questions
parce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que les les 50%
de nucléaire en 2025 avait vocation être
une ambition politique et pas un
objectif normatif
donc lorsque ce n'est pas un objectif
normatif à Vénissieux ça pose pas de
problème de sécurité d'approvisionnement
le seul objectif normatif qui figure
dans la loi c'est le plafonnement de la
capacité nucléaire à 63,2 gigawatts qui
prévoyait que si EDF arrivait à mettre
en service LEPR il faudrait qu'elle
ferme enfin que l'autre puisse ferme a
du concurrence une tranche c'était
tonton c'était en l'occurrence
c'était en l'occurrence Fessenheim
donc ça c'est une première chose après
la loi telle que finalement ces
principes ont été débattus ont été
proposés par les administrations et en
tout cas ce que j'ai pu en voir durant
ma présence à Matignon c'est principe de
la loi étaient que la loi allait être
une loi de pilotage et il doit d'outils
et
à part son premier article de son titre
1 cette loi est très volumineuse hyper
technique elle comporte de mémoire alors
je les là j'ai oublié de j'ai pas compté
les articles mais on doit dépasser les
et c'est une noix de pilotage et c'est
une noix de pilotage qui prévoit la
stratégie nationale bas carbone qui
prévoit la mise en place de la PPE et
qui prévoit tout un tas de dispositifs
qui ont vocation e à garantir la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en fonction
des paramètres qui changent et les
paramètres qui changent c'est la
consommation et les paramètres qui
changent c'est la manière dont la France
est capable de mettre en place des des
énergies renouvelables plus ou moins
vite les paramètres qui changent ça va
être ça peut être une nouvelle stratégie
nationale bas carbone qui elle-même fait
la part plus ou moins belle au
bioénergie et selon la part plus ou
moins belle que vous faites au bio
énergie
et bien ça joue sur la part de
l'électricité donc le monde de l'énergie
c'est un monde de vases communicants
donc
cet objectif de 50%
en 2025 dont je note que la question des
50% n'était pas tellement polémique
c'était la question des 2025 qu'il était
puisque les débats de la ltecv en
2014-2015 montre que les groupes
politiques de droite ou de gauche
avait assez largement partagé l'objectif
des 50%
. ce qui faisait des basses c'était 2025
versus 2030 versus 2035 et là c'était
une pure question d'ambition politique
qui qui
n'était pas normative en revanche ce qui
dans la loi allait être normatif c'était
bien mettre en place les outils de
gouvernement très opérationnels pour
garantir que la France
maintienne sa sécurité
d'appro notamment
dans une PPE en se fondant sur des
études de sécurité d'appro
fait par nous
et d'ailleurs ça a marché puisque dans
le bilan prévisionnel 2021 que j'ai
présenté à la presse je crois que
c'était en mars 2021 j'ai dit que les
études de RTE ne permettait pas de
fermer de nouvelles tranches nucléaires
en 2026 qui était une option à la fois
pour des raisons d'émissions de CO2 et à
la fois pour des questions de sécurité
d'appro
et donc ces tranches n'ont pas vocation
à être fermées voilà
que les difficultés de sécurité
d'approvisionnement que la France
rencontre cet hiver
ne sont dus en rien
à désorientations
de politiques publiques que ça relève de
la loi no-home de la loi
ltecv d'une PPE quelconque la France
rencontre des problèmes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement cet hiver parce que
le parc nucléaire est indisponible c'est
ça qui se passe
et je vais vous en donner les grandes
proportions
le parc nucléaire français
entre 2000 et 2015
produisait environ 400 tt par an
400 entre 2016 et 2019 il produisait en
moyenne 385
terawattheure d'électricité par an
l'année du covid il produisait 330
terabateurs par an
cette année il produira de l'ordre de
280 terwattheure par an ce qui veut dire
qu'entre 2015 et 2022 nous sommes passés
de 400 TW à 280 TER le parc nucléaire a
perdu 25%
et lorsque vous êtes le moyen
d'alimentation des Français hyper
dominants perdent 25% c'est
effectivement très douloureux
je vous remercie avant de passer à ce
point qui est l'hiver actuel je reviens
sur 20 sur la période 2012-2015 ce que
vous dites en creux en éco aussi à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est que
l'objectif de 50%
n'implique pas en lui-même après
d'autres mesures interviennent mais
n'implique pas en lui-même une forme de
remplacement comme on a pu le dire ou
qu'on peut le lire du du nucléaire par
les énergies renouvelables étant donné
les prévisions de consommation qui était
qui était en vigueur à l'époque enfin
qui était les plus raisonnables à
l'époque et donc l'idée du 50% n'est pas
forcément de d'un vaste communicant
entre le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables et qui a une forme de
confusion entre la proportion en
pourcentage et la réalité de la
production effectivement
disons que la ltecv elle dit pas que 50%
nucléaires la ltecv dans son article 1
elle lisse tout un tas d'objectifs
climatiques de d'ambition de
développement des énergies renouvelables
enfin la France a pas donc attendu la
ltecv pour dire qu'il fallait faire des
énergies renouvelables vite possible se
dire c'est historiquement dans les
textes sur l'énergie ça fait quand même
de nombreuses années qu'on dit et puis
ça fait quand même de nombreuses années
que la France fait partie de l'Union
européenne qui est le même prend des
engagements de développement d'énergie
renouvelable donc
c'est un texte qui affiche un certain
nombre de de
d'ambition et de proportions vous avez
raison de dire que
[Musique]
que 50% dont il est question c'est 50%
de la production donc ça dépend pas de
la consommation et d'une certaine
manière ça laisse libre
ce qui dirige le pays c'est-à-dire vous
de au fur et à mesure de gérer les
proportions du du
mix électrique fondamentalement c'est
bien une question de
rééquilibrage
de la manière dont on produit de
l'électricité mais je suis frappé par le
fait que on se résume en disant que
c'est une question de NR contre le reste
du monde ou de nucléaire contre la
seconde c'est pas ça le sujet il y a des
questions de diversification au sein des
ENR il y a des questions de résilience
au sein des ENR aussi à se poser et au
sein du du nucléaire mais
je partage avec vous que
cet objectif politique n'était pas
normatif
n'implique pas automatiquement
euh
n'aurait pas impliqué automatiquement
des fermetures à la chaîne mais il n'en
reste pas moins que c'était un moyen de
pousser la France à faire des ENR le
plus vite possible voilà
c'est le privilège du président
une dernière question sur cette période
à de multiples reprises et notamment la
gestion des yeux à un avis de l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire en 2013 il est il
est il est question de potentiel des
faux générique grave sans pouvoir bien
sûr dire lequel et notamment cet avis
2013 de la SN dit je cite la SN rappelle
l'importance de disposer de marge
suffisante dans le système électrique
pour faire face à la nécessité de
suspendre simultanément le
fonctionnement de plusieurs réacteurs
qui présenterait un défaut générique
grave est-ce que lorsque vous étiez au
responsabilités au cabinet du premier
ministre les échanges que vous aviez
avec EDF les échanges que vous aviez
avec RTE traduisait le fait traduisait
cette inquiétude chez ses acteurs là
est-ce que c'était un sujet d'inquiétude
un sujet de préoccupation ou est-ce que
comme vous avez pu le dire sur la partie
abondance de l'électricité finalement le
contexte énergétique dans lequel on se
situait que cette alerte de la SN avait
l'air essentiellement formelle
de la SN n'est jamais purement formelle
c'est toujours très sérieux
moi je veux bien qu'on parle de marge
mais en fait la question c'est des
marches par rapport à quoi
quand on fait de l'électricité on
s'occupe de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement ça a été mon cas
quand j'étais conseiller du Premier
ministre et ça a été mon cas et c'est
mon cas depuis que je suis président de
de RTE et donc lorsqu'on s'occupe de la
sécurité de l'approvisionnement le seul
la seule question qui compte c'est
est-ce qu'on respecte le critère des
trois heures de défaillance des marchés
puisque c'est le droit
et Mesdames et Messieurs aujourd'hui
nous ne le respectons pas c'est pour ça
que nous sommes en difficulté et nous et
nous dans le respectons pas de très loin
donc
donc c'est ça qui joue
donc moi je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
avoir des marges parce que on peut pas
dire que
ce soit les problèmes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui se soit imposé
ou question de sûreté nucléaire je veux
dire ça tout le temps était l'inverse
c'est la sûreté nucléaire qui impose la
disponibilité du parc et c'est la sécu à
Pau qui est qui en est la conséquence la
preuve ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
et bien c'est pour des raisons de sûreté
que les réacteurs qui étaient frappés
par la corrosion sous contrainte sont à
l'arrêt et c'est bien priorité à la
sûreté et c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui s'adapte en
l'occurrence à la s'adapte mal donc moi
je sais pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire c'est marge ce qui est important
c'est que moi je me souviens plus de cet
avis de de la SN mais ce qui est
important c'est que des qu'on discute de
marge on discute par rapport à quoi par
rapport à quel niveau de service on veut
ça c'est une première chose et puis donc
une deuxième chose c'est que
il faut qu'on se demande combien la
collectivité nationale est prête à
mettre dans le financement de ces marges
je vais prendre un exemple
simple si les gens nous nous regardent
puisque nous sommes diffusés on pourrait
tout à fait concevoir que un pays x
décide que pour toujours avoir
suffisamment de marge nucléaires il est
toujours un certain nombre de réacteur
en stock
en plus au cas où certains tombent
vraiment en panne bon c'est toujours
possible mais ça a un coup et ça finit
sur la facture des des Français le
système électrique historiquement c'est
un système qui est optimisé le critère
des trois heures de défaillance il
optimise le coût complet du système
électrique
les marges
ce que la sûreté impose fait perdre des
marges à la sécurité d'appro ça peut
être vrai CF en ce moment précis la
question de la SN entre en 2013 été la
question des marges opérationnelles pour
exploiter à chaque à chaque minute le
système électrique la pas d'inquiétude
nous avons des réserves c'est ce que
j'ai vite c'est ce que j'ai évoquai tout
à l'heure une réserve primaire une
réserve secondaire une une réserve
tertiaire et donc rTE est aujourd'hui
elle a toujours été capable d'aller
chercher de l'électricité pour faire
saigner gros réglages en temps réel et
que chaque Français puisse avoir de
l'électricité lorsqu'il le souhaite
voilà
en méthode poser la question d'une marge
c'est se demander par rapport à quoi et
en tout cas on ne peut pas dire que
jamais la France les prix des décisions
au détriment de la sûreté c'est toujours
la sûreté qui s'est imposée au reste y
compris à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement CF en ce moment ce
qui est en train de se passer sur
l'hiver 23 24 22 23 pardon excusez-moi
ma question était beaucoup plus triviale
que votre réponse en fait c'était est-ce
que dans vos amener à Matignon vous avez
eu dans votre bureau des dirigeants du
monde du monde des énergéticiens ou des
administrations qui vous ont dit
effectivement la SM mentionne risque de
défaut génériques on pourrait quand même
se poser la question de ce qui se
passerait en l'état de notre système de
production électrique avec en plus
progressivement au fur et à mesure des
années l'idée de fermer des capacités
pilotables on peut on peut peut-être
s'inquiéter pour cette sécurité
approvisionnement concrètement est-ce
que c'est arrivé ou pas on cherche pas
de responsabilité individuelle mais
excusez-moi c'est vers c'est rouge c'est
bon euh non j'ai j'ai pas le souvenir
qu'un dirigeant ce soit venu me parler
de l'hypothèse d'un défaut générique
mais la question de l'hypothèse d'un
défaut générique elle est dans la tête
de tous ceux qui font de l'énergie et de
tous ceux qui s'occupent du nucléaire
parce qu'il peut arriver voilà et donc
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle la
question de la diversification au sein
de la famille nucléaire et de la
diversification entre les modes de
production d'électricité et aussi
important c'est que ça peut arriver
et bien évidemment ça peut poser une
question de sécurité d'appro donc toute
personne qui fait de l'énergie se pose
la question que vous vous posez mesdames
et messieurs qui sont dans quelle mesure
pouvons-nous être plus souvent
parce que ça pose des problèmes de
principe parce que ça pose des problèmes
de dépendance puis aussi ça peut poser
des problèmes économiques CF le prix du
gaz en ce moment et toute personne qui
fait de l'électricité se pose en base la
question de la sécurité d'appro et de la
résilience qui peut porter atteint à
cette sécurité d'appro je dirais c'est
presque ontologique à la question de
faire de l'énergie lorsque vous êtes
énergéticien ou vous occupez d'énergie
vous vous préoccupez de savoir si les
Français vont avoir de l'énergie que
vous fassiez du pétrole du gaz ou de
l'électricité quel que soit son mode de
production
je vous remercie Jean bien justement la
question de sécurité approvisionnement
vos fonctions chez RTE vous mentionnez
dans le rapport futur énergétique mais
je crois que c'est déjà mentionné avant
la question du critère ce qui permet
tout simplement d'estimer de mesurer la
sécurité d'approvisionnement vous avez
parlé du critère des trois heures et
dans le rapport vous écrivez enfin RTE
écrit je cite à propos du de la question
de la sécurité approvisionnement et du
risque je cite RTE a déjà eu l'occasion
de mentionner que ce critère était
fruste dans la mesure où il identifiait
il identifiait la probabilité de
survenue d'une situation de déséquilibre
et non s'approfondeur et donc sa gravité
est-ce que vous jugez que les outils qui
existent aujourd'hui sont suffisants
pour que le pouvoir politique puisse
librement déterminer de ça de niveau de
souveraineté énergétique du pays et donc
d'envisager d'anticiper une crise telle
que nous la vivons avec deux multiples
facteurs et des chocs externes aux
géopolitiques
non le critère des trois heures est
frustre et il n'est pas suffisant c'est
la raison pour laquelle RTO fait des
stress test au-delà de la question du
critère et on se contente pas d'avoir
une analyse probabidiste centrée sur
trois heures on fait des tresses pour
tester la profondeur des défaillances
possibles
et donc c'est défaillances
possibles elles peuvent être importantes
c'est la queue de distribution donc
elles peuvent être importantes mais
elles sont très faibles probabilité
après c'est une question de donc
appréciation du risque mais oui on a dit
que c'était frustre oui je le pense oui
il y a du travail à faire là dessus mais
on n'a pas attendu la modification des
textes européens et réglementaires
français pour faire nous-même des stress
test et pour éclairer le politique sur
ce que ça pourrait donner voilà
donc ça c'était
ma réponse est j'ai oublié
la deuxième à votre interpellation c'est
pas grave ça va me revenir
[Musique]
non honnêtement je crois que je crois
qu'il faut qu'on se dise que qu'il
faudra qu'on progresse dessus d'ailleurs
on en parle avec avec le mystère de
l'énergie déjà
et je crois que
je crois que plus le mix va se
diversifier plus la France va faire des
énergies renouvelables parce que nous
avons démontré dans le futur énergétique
que quoi qu'on décidait sur le nouveau
nucléaire et même si on en faisait
beaucoup il faudrait beaucoup d'énergie
renouvelables demain et donc il fallait
en faire le plus vite possible tout de
suite
et que la présence de ces énergies
renouvelables variables conduit à mettre
en place des stress test complémentaires
à la question de ce critère des trois
heures qui est un critère en probabilité
centrée pardon sur pour ces horribles
termes
non je vous remercie et alors
application en pratique à partir de 2017
et en particulier dans le bilan
prévisionnel 2019 vous identifiez les
années sensibles les hivers pendant
lesquels on peut être en
particulièrement en difficulté vous avez
expliqué que vos rapports étaient
publics qui sont transmis évidemment au
gouvernement et aux ministres qui
j'imagine dans des échanges avec vous
sur les points les plus saillants est-ce
que dès l'identification alors vous
étiez pas encore
à la tête de RTE mais si j'ai bien
compris vous y étiez déjà et puis par la
suite est-ce que vous avez connaissance
d'échanges avec le gouvernement les
membres du gouvernement au fur et à
mesure sur ces hivers sensibles qui
arrivent et qui font la tension d'une
vigilance croissante de la part de RTE
et si oui qu'elles sont les réflexions
que vous partagez avec le avec le
gouvernement quelles sont les réponses
du gouvernement
je peux pas répondre à cette question
parce que j'étais chez RTE en fin 2015
et le 1er septembre 2020 date à laquelle
je suis devenu président mais
fonctionnellement je m'occupais à part
de ces questions au sein de de
l'organigramme donc je ne peux pas vous
répondre je n'ai pas cette information
alors à partir de 2020 oui il y a des
échanges sur sur le manque de marge et
sur ce et sur la sensibilité de ces
années de cette séquence
2021-2025 parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on sait que ce serait difficile parce
que ça fait longtemps qu'on sait que les
moyens thermiques
on fermait parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on sait que la France est en retard
sur tout son plan d'énergie renouvelable
et parce que ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait que les centrales vont avoir 40 ans
à ce moment-là et parce que ça fait
quelques années qu'on mesure l'ampleur
de ce qu'est le grand carénage et les
retards possibles que ça peut générer et
à l'époque on n'avait pas prévu ni le
covid ni la corrosion sous contrainte
mais même avant
ces deux événements qui ont un impact
sur la sur la disponibilité du parc oui
ça fait longtemps que RTE dit que ce
serait des années difficiles qui ont
empiré du fait de la survenue à la fois
du covid qui a des organisé
certains aspects de la maintenance sur
le parc nucléaire et surtout de cette
corrosion sous contrainte qui a rendu le
parc encore plus indisponible que prévu
et oui nous en parlons parce que lorsque
le gouvernement
aujourd'hui fait en sorte que la
centrale de Saint-Avold
puisse tourner un certain nombre
d'heures supplémentaire et ben c'est
issu de nobilans prévisionnels dans
laquelle j'ai dit que outre le fait que
RTE
donc considéré qu'on ne pouvait pas donc
activer l'option
de fermeture de deux tranches nucléaires
en 2026 j'ai dit et démontré que il
était souhaitable que la France garde
les deux centrales à charbon
à l'époque il y avait pas la corrosion
sous contrainte et donc par extension
Saint-Avold en service jusqu'en 2024
voire 2026 parce que du point de vue de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement cela
nous aider donc oui il y a des échanges
avec les pouvoirs publics sur les marges
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on dit qu'on
aurait des difficultés de marche dans
cette période qui sont finalement pire
que prévu avec la survenue de ces deux
de ces deux événements imprévisibles le
covid et la
corrosion sous contrainte et on n'a pas
des échanges avec le gouvernement que ça
c'est on a fait en sorte que
on a aidé le gouvernement à faire des
propositions très opérationnelles qui
ont été votées récemment par votre
assemblée lors de la loi
urgence pouvoir d'achat pour la
mobilisation de groupes électrogène 7 et
cet hiver pour l'optimisation des offres
d'effacement sur le mécanisme
d'ajustement ça c'est issu d'un travail
avec RTE comme il est issu d'un travail
avec RTE et avec enedis les
modifications qui sont au vote en ce
moment sur le raccordement des énergies
renouvelables et l'accélération de leur
installation donc oui nous avons
beaucoup d'échanges avec les pouvoirs
publics à la fois sur la manière dont on
gère le système électrique mais aussi
sur les réformes qu'on pourrait poser
sur la table pour accélérer notre
transition et pour gagner à la fois donc
en résilience dont j'ai beaucoup parlé
mais tout simplement pour améliorer nos
marges cet hiver
je vous remercie quelques dernières
questions sur les fameuses scénarios de
futurs énergétiques 2050 d'abord une
première question enfin un constat
simplement de vérification on a beaucoup
entendu y compris nos récents
interlocuteurs
estimé que la limitation de la puissance
installée du nucléaire conduisait une
baisse du nucléaire ou en tout cas
condamner la filière nucléaire en France
mais pourtant dans aucun de vos
scénarios y compris les plus
volontaristes prend le plus volontariste
en matière nucléaire le n03 on a 27
gigawatts installé en nouveau nucléaire
et 24 gigawatts installés en nucléaire
historique donc en fait finalement même
dans les scénarios les plus
volontaristes le plafond d'un peu plus
de 60 GW de puissance installée n'a pas
d'impact sur les options énergétiques
qui s'ouvrent au pays d'après les
scénarios que vous présentez
non ça n'a pas d'impact alors pourquoi
ça n'a pas la pâte parce que
[Musique]
on a simulé la fermeture du parc
installé de deuxième génération c'est
avec le parc installé deuxième
génération il a été mis en service dans
une vingtaine d'années plutôt plutôt
assez concentré et donc il a vocation en
prenant l'hypothèse que le fa que
l'essentiel du parc ferme à 60 ans ce
qui ce qui est je le rappelle une
hypothèse qui ne serait pas validé par
Bernardo duxili était à mes côtés
puisque lui ne peut se prononcer que
jusqu'à 50 ans pour le moment bon mais
nous on a pris des hypothèses de
prolongation de l'essentiel du parc à 60
ans mais même dans cette hypothèse là le
parc nucléaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui il sera fermé en 2060
bon donc le sujet c'est par quoi est-ce
qu'on remplace ça pour être à l'heure de
la neutralité carbone en 2050 donc faire
le plus d'électricité possible
bah il faut dans nos scénarios on peut
faire des EPM des EPERS de c'est pas la
seule techno on peut faire des SMS enfin
c'est pas le design n'est pas encore mûr
et donc la question qui se pose c'est
combien de paires la France est capable
de faire rapidement pour produire de
dans ces scénarios je dirais nucléaire
pour produire un maximum de nucléaires à
cet échange de 2050 dans le futur
énergétique vous savez que énormément de
concertation de dialogue avec les
parties prenantes les filières les
industriels etc et ce qui est ressorti
de ce dialogue
dont les écrits sont en ligne sont
publiques sont transparents et ce qui
est ressorti de ce dialogue notamment
donc avec EDF la sphène et le gifen
était que 14 tranches de pr
mise en service en 2050 était une forme
de maximum industriel à date
et bah effectivement c'est 14 paires en
2050 ça empêche pas d'en faire d'autres
après mais nous nous jalons c'est 2050
donc la question c'est quel nombre
maximum de paires peut-on construire qui
fonctionne et qui produisent à pleine
puissance pour 2050 et donc
effectivement ça conduit à une puissance
installée 2pr 23 GW
en 2050 tous les réacteurs de deuxième
génération n'ont pas encore fermé qui
restent à peu près 16
gigawatts mais quand bien même la France
arriverait à faire des SMS
et même à prolonger certaines tranches à
60 ans nous ne sommes pas au plafond des
63,2 gigawatts vous avez raison on ne
sature pas finalement le plafond
nucléaire qui a été voté en en 2015
c'est pas un choix idéologique du tout
c'est simplement
issu d'une discussion avec la filière
industrielle et et
si vous souhaitez les contributions
écrites de cette filière industrielle
sont en ligne sur le site de RTE je vous
l'ai dit nos études sont publiques et
ainsi que les contributions des acteurs
merci donc une question à tiroir
là-dessus pour être sûr de bien
comprendre on lira les échanges
évidemment avec beaucoup d'attention
mais des échanges que vous avez avec les
filières la filière sur la question du
nucléaire ce 14 va se 27 gigawatts de
nouveau nucléaires installés que vous
qualifiez comme un maximum est-ce que au
vu des échanges que vous avez avec la
filière que vous avez eu avec la filière
vous qualifiez vous qualifieriez la
crédibilité de cet objectif ou de ce
nombre de fortes de moyenne ou de faible
écoutez c'est
presque un jugement de valeur de la
filière que vous me demandez donc je
sais c'est très difficile de répondre ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que il est
improbable que la France se met en
service les deux premiers EPR de Pandi
parce que c'est le site qui est choisi
avant 2035
que la perte suivante si elle est
arrivée que les deux pères suivantes
si on se dépêche arriverait d'ici 2040
donc ça nous en ferait 60040 il faudrait
qu'on en fasse suite entre 2040 et 2050
donc il faudrait qu'on fasse une tranche
par an ou presque
pour que chacun se rende compte de ce
qui se passe bon donc il faut il faut à
la fois construire dans dans cette
décennie là construire un opère parents
le mettre en service
le couplet et donc effectivement c'est
c'est très ambitieux je peux pas dire
autre chose que c'est très ambitieux moi
je souhaite que
je souhaite que si les dirigeants
politiques français choisissent ce
chemin je souhaite qu'on réussisse
puisque dans ma position
qui doit s'assurer de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement des Français rien
n'est pire que de se fixer des objectifs
qu'on n'atteint pas sur un mode de
production d'électricité parce que si
pendant ce temps-là donc on fait pas
d'efforts sur l'autre on se retrouve
avec des manques à la fin
et donc à rien ne serait pire que de se
retrouver dans un monde où la France
promet de faire beaucoup de pairs et n'y
parviendrait pas pendant qu'elle ne
ferait pas les efforts nécessaires sur
les énergies renouvelables pensant que
les EPR vont venir à la rescousse pour
qu'on se retrouve en 2040 ou en 2050
avec des problèmes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement donc tous les
chemins qu'on a mis sur le papier sont
possibles ils garantissent tous la
sécurité d'approvisionnement ce qui est
important c'est qu'une fois qu'on
choisit ce chemin et donc j'insiste ce
choix de chemin
relève de ceux qui sont élus par les
Français et ben mon souhait le plus cher
c'est qu'on s'y tienne
mordicus et qu'on ne sort pas de notre
trajectoire si on commence à ressortir
de notre trajectoire comme on l'a fait
pendant de nombreuses années
nous finirons par re- rencontrer des
problèmes de retard et on sera confronté
comme ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés
en ce moment sur la sécurité de la pro
merci ça me produit à ma dernière à ma
dernière question à l'extrême inverse du
spectre vous avez le scénario 100%
renouvelable qui a fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'une étude préalable conjointe
entre RT et l'agence internationale pour
l'énergie en 2021 qui liste les
prérequis techniques
technologiques une étude d'ailleurs qui
conclut que la faisabilité scientifique
n'est pas mise en cause mais qu'elle
implique un certain nombre de Paris
technique industriel important vous
parlez aussi de flexibilité et de
d'investissement dans le réseau et je
vous laisserai revenir dessus mais
peut-être pour nous aider à mieux
comprendre
et je le dis évidemment sans aucun
esprit polémique je prends juste le les
chiffres de production d'électricité par
filière en France du 8 décembre 2022 au
14 décembre 2022 disponible grâce
formidable application économique
du 8-12 du 8 12 au 14 12 la production
d'électricité par le solaire a été d'à
peu près 0 % et la probabilité de
produits la production d'énergie par
source éoliennes a été environ de 2%
et de bioénergie d'environ 1% pour une
puissance installée de l'ordre de 13%
pour l'éolien un peu plus et puis à peu
près 10% pour le photovoltaïque est-ce
que vous pouvez nous aider à comprendre
ce qui enfin le monde dans lequel on a
on a une production électrique 100%
énergies renouvelable quelles sont les
conditions techniques et les
implications
alors dans nos scénarios qui tendent
vers 100% renouvelables et qu'on a donc
étudié avec le même intérêt et la même
application que les autres sans parti
pris c'est à la fois des mondes dans
lesquels il faut multiplier les les
installations de production par un
chiffre
considérable sur le sur le solaire il
faudrait qu'on multiplie la capacité
installée par 22
par rapport à ce qu'on avait en 2021
sur l'éolien terrestre il faudrait que
on le multiplie de l'ordre de X4 et sur
Love Shore il faudrait le multiplier par
soit 0 soit l'infini parce que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre on en avait pas alors
maintenant qu'on a Saint-Nazaire
on en a 0,5 il faudrait qu'on atteigne
au moins 45 GW
on est on part de 0,5 et il faudrait
qu'on atteigne 45
donc qu'on fasse fois
90 bon cela dit la France aura mis en
service plusieurs park of Shore dans les
années qui viennent enfin c'est quand
même un effort d'implantation assez
considérable 1 donc ça se voit et ça et
ça se voit et ça occupe de l'espace
après on a montré avec l'agence
intentionnelle de l'énergie
qu'effectivement ces systèmes étaient
pilotables scientifiques techniquement
enfin qui avait pas de barrières
scientifique à condition de lever
quelques aspects technologiques qui sont
encore à la à l'étape de développement
ça veut surtout dire qu'il faut beaucoup
de flexibilité parce que les énergies
renouvelables variables elles sont
variables et donc oui il y a des hivers
sans vent oui il y a des hivers avec
vent il y a des moments où il y a
beaucoup de soleil les monts il y a peu
de soleil donc la lumière quand même
pour l'essentiel elle fait un peu
marcher le solaire et qui a moins de
variabilité sur la luminosité que sur le
vent mais oui il y a des années sont
bons et donc le sujet quand on s'occupe
de sécurité de la pro c'est
si le pays faisait le choix de se
diriger vers un mix 100% renouvelable de
quel type de flexibilité nous aurions
besoin pour que ce système soit
pilotable et qu'on garantisse la
sécurité d'approvisionnement comme
aujourd'hui
enfin comme aujourd'hui horcry sur le
nucléaire comme on devrait le faire
normalement
bon bah ça donc on a dimensionné et donc
c'est des investissements c'est des
dispositifs techniques et donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce sujet avec la question des
réseaux qui rend les mix 100%
renouvelables plus coûteux pour la
collectivité c'est le poste réseau parce
que ça tout le monde comprend que les
EnR sont éparpillés sur le territoire
donc il y a plus de fils
et c'est le poste flexibilité parce que
oui il faut des investissements pour
compenser la variabilité
alors ces flexibilité il en faut du coup
beaucoup si on est dans des mondes dans
lequel on tend vers 100% renouvelable
alors des flexibilité dans notre monde
il y en a 5
il y a les flexibilités de consommation
c'est à dire avoir des dispositifs
techniques qui nous permettent de
moduler notre consommation d'électricité
bon c'était le cas de tempo lorsque
c'était la très largement commercialisé
ça existe encore d'une certaine manière
c'est le cas des cowatts qui va nous
servir à passer l'hiver sans coupure
donc c'est la flexibilité de
consommation premier levier de
flexibilité près deuxième levier c'est
les interconnexions il en faut c'est un
moyen
d'agrandir l'effet du foisonnement
et c'est très efficace économiquement
c'est le moyen de flexibilité le moins
cher de partager les flexibilités entre
les pays donc nous on a dit qu'il
fallait des interconnexions ça pose pas
de problème de souveraineté dans le
cadre de l'Union
et au contraire que ça nous rendait
service c'est que c'était bon pour pour
la facture des consommateurs français
et après il y a il y a trois moyens de
flexibilité qui sont du stockage le
premier c'est les step mais vous savez
que la France a quand même un potentiel
assez limité de développement de ces
steps qui est quand même probable que la
France ne construira plus d'énormes
barrages majeurs comme on l'a construit
dans la première moitié du
du 20e siècle
et puis après il y a les batteries
stationnaires
c'est la chimie dans des 100%
renouvelables il en faut beaucoup et
c'est très lié à la technologie du
solaire et puis enfin l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène produit par électrolyse
qu'on stock et qu'on reconsomme dans des
centrales thermiques et nous avons
dimensionné le nombre de centrales
thermiques qui marcherait à l'hydrogène
des carbonée dont la France aurait
besoin
si elle décidait de s'orienter vers un
mix 100% renouvelable ce serait de
l'ordre d'une soixantaine de centrales à
gaz hydrogène vers qu'il faudrait pour
garantir la sécurité d'approvisionnement
aujourd'hui l'ordre de grandeur pour
vous ayez une référence la France a une
vingtaine de tranches une vingtaine de
centrales à gaz donc il faudrait
multiplier par 3 ce nombre de centrales
à gaz mais bien sûr il faudrait qu'elle
marche à l'hydrogène produit par
électrolyse c'est pas donc c'est de
l'hydrogène produit sans émission de CO2
il y a des prototypes de centrales
hydrogène qui existent en Europe pour
des toutes petites puissances d'ici 2050
c'est pas du tout exclu c'est même tout
à fait probable que les européens seront
développés ces technologies donc
oui c'est un chemin difficile ce 100%
renouvelable oui il faut des
flexibilités elles sont de 5 familles
elles ont tout un coup
et c'est la raison pour lesquelles ces
mix sont plus sont plus chers notamment
pour compenser la variabilité
intercaisonière et même inter-annuelle
parce que comme je vous dis il y a des
années sans vent et donc il faut que
nous puissions garantir aux Français que
cette question est bien traitée
merci beaucoup madame manier milfort
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
monsieur le Président une petite
doléance et je sais pas de combien de
temps dispose monsieur puisazic mais je
crois que notre rendez-vous c'est 9h à
11h ce matin et du coup nous commençons
à peine les questions des autres membres
de la commission oui mais du coup
typiquement notre rapporteur a commencé
ces questions à 10h30 vous voyez ce que
je veux dire et donc du coup ça a fait
un décalage pour nous tous et j'ai vu
des collègues partir qui n'ont pas pu
rester merci monsieur le Président
moi je voudrais souligner sur le même
propos que que le rapporteur peut-être
que il est important que notre
commission d'enquête elle se elle cible
principalement la compréhension de ce
qui s'est passé en termes d'énergie ces
dernières années pour qu'on puisse
effectivement faire les meilleurs choix
pour le futur et qu'effectivement on se
garde d'essayer de chercher des
responsabilités individuelles qui sont
évidemment diffuses qui sont évidemment
chaque fois contextualisés par des
compréhensions et des savoirs qui
étaient ceux de chaque époque et je
crois que c'est ça c'est quelque chose
qui faut rappeler
et redire
monsieur le Président que j'habite vous
avez dit quelque chose qui était
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui
finalement le sujet c'est l'électricité
c'est 25% finalement de notre mix
énergétique global et donc quelque part
on est en train de faire reposer sur vos
épaules et à vous et RTE et à tous les
tout le monde de l'électricité 100% d'un
problème alors qu'en réalité vous n'avez
pas 100% du problème tout seul sur vos
épaules 50% des besoins énergétiques
français sont notamment des besoins de
chaleur et c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous avez assez peu de visibilité vous
en tant que président de RTE de la même
façon que les producteurs d'électricité
ou les acteurs du nucléaire ou de
l'éolien ou des eénères électriques ont
finalement assez peu de savoir et de
maîtrise est-ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression que de ce point de vue là
sur la question de la chaleur
renouvelable on est finalement un peu à
l'aveugle sur ces sur ces sujets
il y a eu un rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui soulignait en 2018
alors certes les soutiens aux onlr
électrique en disant attention à terme
ça pourrait coûter 40 milliards
notamment le soutien aux éoliennes ça
avait d'ailleurs généré une commission
d'enquête sur les EnR sous le mandature
précédente dont j'étais rapporteur et
c'était avant n'est-ce pas que la
situation actuelle fasse que les
éoliennes rapportent finalement à l'état
7,6 milliards donc ça non plus à
l'époque on menait la commission
d'enquête on ne le savait pas mais la
Cour des comptes en 2018 souligne
surtout qu'il y avait un soutien très
insuffisant aux one NR thermique et que
elle considérait qu'on avait là encore
une forme d'aveuglement en ayant surtout
un soutien aux ovnr électrique donc ça
c'est c'est ma première question la
deuxième de la même façon vous l'avez
dit dans l'équation qui est la nôtre il
y a une part importante qui est celle de
la sobriété énergétique et là encore
c'est finalement un sujet sur lequel
vous avez assez peu de visibilité sur la
capacité qu'on a à être dans la sobriété
énergétique vous avez mentionné les
réglementations thermiques dans votre
propos liminaire et c'est vrai que moi
qui m'intéresse beaucoup au secteur du
bâtiment comme secteur consommateur
d'énergie très importante je rappelle
que le secteur des bâtiments c'est 700
térawattheure par an de consommation
énergétique finale que 700 wattheure par
an c'est du coup plus de deux fois la
production du parc nucléaire français
donc c'est un volume énergétique
absolument massif et qu'une grande part
de ce besoin énergétique du bâtiment
c'est un besoin de chaleur est-ce que
vous pensez vous en votre connaissance
énergétique qu'il est absolument
pertinent de remplacer 100% des besoins
énergétiques par des besoins électriques
ou est-ce que vous pensez qu'au
contraire on doit essayer dans le
secteur des bâtiments d'aller chercher
des réponses d'énergie thermique pour
aller chercher des besoins de couvrir
les besoins de chaleur du secteur du
bâtiment
vous avez mentionné et je pense que
c'est une réalité que les
réglementations thermiques
sont un sujet dans notre dans notre
débat sur la souveraineté énergétique
française je voudrais me rappeler
quelque chose qui a été mis en avant par
le conseil pour le climat dans le cadre
de son rapport sur la rénovation
énergétique il disait que dans les
années 70 quand on avait été confronté à
la dernière crise grande crise
pétrolière les choix des différents pays
avaient été variés et qu'en France le
choix avait été de lancer une production
électrique très importante donc c'était
l'idée d'une production abondante
massive qui devait courir les sujets et
qu'on a repoussé les règles de
performance thermique des bâtiments a
beaucoup plus tard dans le même temps
dans les autres pays Européens on a mis
en place des réglementations thermiques
dans les années 70 que nous nous l'avons
mis en place qu'en 2012 ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un parc
énergétique français bâti extrêmement
énergivores extrêmement électrique
en sachant que quand on compare le coût
des énergies par mètre carré mais on se
rend compte ça c'est des chiffres que
j'ai de 2020 mais ils ont dû bouger
évidemment ces derniers temps que au
mètre carré comparativement le bois
coûtait 5,8 euros au mètre carré à
chauffer le gaz c'était 11,7 euros le
fioul 12,9 euros et l'électricité
arrivait à 15,9 euros du mètre carré à
chauffer donc électricité en fait était
l'énergie la plus chère pour assurer le
chauffage des Français et nous avons
aujourd'hui des charges énergétiques sur
les Français qui sont extrêmement
lourdes pour les questions à nouveau de
chauffage donc ma question c'est est-ce
que sur ces sujets là est-ce qu'on n'a
pas intérêt à changer la perception du
secteur des bâtiments qui a été vu comme
un consommateur énergétique et pas un
allié de la transition énergétique c'est
vrai qu'en 2012 on lui a imposé une
réglementation thermique était très
gazière en disant qu'effectivement le
gaz était la solution je pense qu'à
l'époque en 2012 ça a été fait notamment
pour des questions sociales comme je
leur mets dans la question des coûts du
chauffage mais mais effectivement le
secteur des bâtiments il a installé ce
qu'on lui demandait d'installer et de la
même façon en 2020 dans la RE20 on est
passé à une réglementation très
électrique et de la même façon on
installera dans le secteur de bâtiments
s'il le faut de l'électricité mais ce
qu'on entend du secteur des bâtiments et
des acteurs qui sont gestionnaires de
l'énergie à l'échelle des bâtiments
c'est qu'en fait il faudrait avoir une
beaucoup plus de parcimonie finalement
dans les réglementations thermiques et
que la gestion énergétique à l'échelle
du bâtiment c'est une solution et vous
avez mentionné les problématiques de
stockage et les problématiques de
flexibilité là encore avec ces 700 tt
d'énergie consommée le secteur des
bâtiments pourrait être un très grand
comment dire
pourvoyeur de flexibilité dans le réseau
énergétique notamment parce que dans le
secteur des bâtiments on peut stocker
dans la chaleur on peut stocker vous le
savez c'est d'ailleurs une réalité le
meilleur lieu de stockage ce sont les
chauffe-eau des Français qui font que
même dans nos consommations énergétiques
on prend nos douches en France plutôt le
matin parce que on chargeait le
chauffe-eau la nuit avec l'électricité
nucléaire qui était effectivement
abondante donc en fait aujourd'hui le
secteur des bâtiments c'est un lieu de
pilotage de l'énergie des Français de la
consommation énergétique des Français et
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que on ne
rend pas vraiment les Français alliés de
cette de cette consommation on nous a
dit longtemps que la consommation des
Français n'était pas pilotable et qu'il
fallait pour cela avoir une production
énergétique continue aujourd'hui avec le
le
seul l'application Ecowatt on se rend
bien compte qu'on demande aux Français
de faire un effort de
le citoyens d'engagement dans l'énergie
en tant que consommateur acteur et comme
vous avez fait un effort extrêmement
important et je veux le saluer de
pédagogie pour essayer d'expliquer les
sujets énergétiques comment est-ce qu'on
peut effectivement rendre de la même
façon le secteur de bâtiment davantage
acteur et moins consommateurs plus un
allié et moins quelques quelque part une
une échappatoire de la production
énergétique telle que penser ailleurs
voilà mes questions
alors
je vais commencer par la question de
des de la chaleur et vous avez dit
qu'on avait peu de
non je vais commencer par votre question
sur le sur la consommation d'énergie
totale et vous m'avez dit vous avez peu
de visibilité on en a on en a on a
repris à notre compte mais de manière
totalement consciente et assumer les
objectifs d'efficacité énergétique de la
SNBC
produite en 2019 comme quoi la France
ferait 40% d'efficacité énergétique
d'ici 2050 tous énergies confondues on
peut le documenter c'est un objectif
relativement ambitieux mais c'est
atteignable et donc on a cette
visibilité là toute énergie après la
difficulté vous savez qu'on a travaillé
un scénario sobriété en matière
d'électricité qui va au-delà de cette
efficacité et qui consiste à dire que si
les Français le souhaitent
en plus d'être efficace ils peuvent être
sobre mais là ça conduit à changer leur
mode de vie sur 26
leviers de donc d'évitement de
consommation d'électricité dans
l'habitat au travail dans la mobilité et
dans la manière
[Musique]
dont
on articule j'ai dit
habitat mobilité
industrie consommation et déplacement
donc on a
donc on a une forme de visibilité toute
énergie mais sur l'électricité on est
capable de simuler des des scénarios
finalement assez précis
vous avez parlé de la partie chaleur qui
dans la SNBC française et dans cette
grande famille des des énergies
renouvelables non électrique
et donc il y en a beaucoup dans la SNBC
on les a reprises à notre compte c'est
une grande part de la consommation en
énergie finale en 2050 et dans cette
famille là
il y a la chaleur produite à base de
biomasse c'est pas oublier simplement ce
qu'on peut constater c'est que c'est
moins documenté que la question
électrique parce que
les acteurs de l'électricité ont une
tradition et c'est peut-être du fait des
problèmes de enfin des problèmes des
questions de sécurité d'approse c'est
qu'on a quand même l'habitude de se
poser la question sur est-ce que ce sont
les bons choix économiques qui sont
faits est-ce que c'est le bon chemin
est-ce que ça rend la France résiliente
est-ce que ça garantit la sécurité
d'approvisionnement si vous me posez la
question moi je vous réponds qu'il
serait souhaitable que du côté de ces
bioénergie et nos cames et notamment
toutes les productions de chaleur à base
de biomasse que ce soit par exemple la
chaleur bois etc on étudie les choses
très précisément pour qu'il y ait une
forme de bouclage c'est à dire est-ce
que la France
dispose de suffisamment de fonciers
agricoles pour produire
des cives donc des cultures instert
saisonnières à vocation énergétique
est-ce que la est-ce que la dynamique de
la forêt française elle permet à la fois
de fournir la construction bois mais
aussi de fournir de la chaleur bois dans
la limite des bois que nous avons
est-ce que finalement les dynamiques
agricoles
et les rendements qui plafonnent
aujourd'hui y compris lorsqu'on fait de
l'agriculture intensive et compatible
avec ses besoins de forêt de demain et
ses besoins de culture dédiés à la
fabrication d'énergie ça c'est quand
même que des bonnes questions
et je rajoute dedans la préservation des
espaces naturels puisque compte tenu des
engagements en matière de protection
d'espace naturel de la France il est
quand même peu probable que les espaces
qui aujourd'hui sont protégés ne sont
pas cultivés le deuxième donc oui qu'un
jour il y a une forme de grand bouclage
scientifique pour se demander si
l'ensemble de la terre qui peut produire
demain
de la biomasse boucle avec nos
politiques agricoles nos gens nos enjeux
de protection de de la biodiversité
c'est très important et je crois qu'à ma
connaissance ce travail enfin un travail
de cette profondeur aujourd'hui n'est
pas réalisé je crois que ce serait
souhaitable qu'il le soit j'ai compris
mais je n'ai pas d'informations
privilégiée que les pouvoirs publics et
que le gouvernement dans la future SNBC
travailler à cette question du Grand
bouclage
sur les bioénergie en tout cas nous
l'avons fait sur la question de
l'électricité je crois que ce serait
souhaitable de le faire sur l'autre
famille de ce dont on a besoin en 2050
c'est c'est les bioénergie que ça
produise de la chaleur ou pas finalement
donc d'accord avec vous sur l'angle mort
sur la place de l'électricité dans le
bâtiment
aujourd'hui l'électricité est
minoritaire dans les bâtiments
demain à la vocation à devenir
majoritaire mais si les bâtiments sont
bien isolés et si c'est des pompes à
chaleur ça pose aucun problème
ça pose aucun problème mais au contraire
c'est bien d'avoir
ce ce vecteur parce que ça nous
permettra et là aussi c'est une question
de pilotage de politique publique au fur
et à mesure enfin ça nous permettra ça
permettra donc à la France de régler
finalement ces politiques publiques
d'équipement de chauffage si
d'aventurier avait un doute sur la
capacité en 2050 de la France de
produire telle ou tel volume de de
bioénergie je crois que c'est bien qu'on
est plusieurs fer au feu toujours cette
résilience pompe à chaleur électrique
pompe à chaleur hybride quel le
dispositif le plus performant le moins
cher celui qui nous protège le plus des
à-coups d'approvisionnement mais il y a
des chemins avec beaucoup
d'électrification dès lors que les
bâtiments sont bien rénovés et qu'on
passe par le dispositif
de la pompe à chaleur et vous me disiez
que le bâtiment n'était pas acteur et
pas consommateur enfin été n'était pas
assez perçu moi je suis pas d'accord
avec vous je
il m'est arrivé publiquement y compris
dans la presse de critiquer le retard à
l'allumage du tertiaire dans le dans les
mesures de sobriété et dans le Relais Du
du signal Ecowatt c'était vrai mais ça
ça bouge ça bouge et d'autres tertiaire
est en train de se mobiliser les
chiffres de la consommation française
en ce moment qu'on a publié mardi soir
montre que la consommation baisse de 9%
par rapport à la moyenne des années 2014
2019 et que le paquet le paquet
tertiaire plus résidentiel c'est moins
8%. donc le monde du bâtiment se
mobilise ok un peu de retard à
l'allumage mais c'est efficace et je
note pour avoir fait donc un événement
récent avec Inès et avec le Gym Elec que
les solutions techniques pour que le
monde du bâtiment rentre dans des mondes
de flexibilité elle existe elles sont
commercialisées elles sont elles sont
faciles à mettre en place et moi je suis
très optimiste sur la manière dont le
monde du bâtiment est en train de se
mobiliser sur les questions énergétiques
au-delà du signal prix qui est donné par
le prix du gaz et celui de l'électricité
je suis très optimiste parce que je le
vois à travers la mobilisation de ces
acteurs autour du dispositif et
très vite très vite pour rebondir sur
deux points et clarifier je parlais pas
du rôle du secteur des bâtiments dans
son rôle de d'économe de l'énergie mais
dans son rôle de prescripteur de la
bonne énergie à installer à l'échelle du
bâtiment et là je trouve que dans ce
rôle là il est très sous-estimé
évidemment sur le rôle de l'économie
d'énergie ils sont très très allant
effectivement
du coup je déduis de vos trois points
parce que je parlais aussi vous m'avez
parler de la biomasse mais moi par
exemple je parle de la géothermie 5
terawattheure aujourd'hui on vient
d'avoir une filière géo énergie qui
vient d'être lancée qui promet sans
Terra water je ne sais pas si ça par
exemple c'est quelque chose que vous
avez dans vos tablettes dans vos
scénarios et si c'est quelque chose que
vous intégrez comme potentiel de
développement et pas seulement sur la
base de ce qui était l'historique prévu
mais du potentiel de développement de
ces filières d'énergie thermique et du
coup sur la question de la recherche et
développement sur les 1,7 milliards et
ils ont augmenté les budgets de la
recherche de 1,2 à 1,7 milliards dans
les dernières années
mais c'est toujours un milliard pour le
nucléaire en recherche et développement
et du coup si je suis d'accord avec vous
sur le fait que sur les EnR termiques on
devrait avoir davantage de moyens de
faire de la recherche pour savoir ce
qu'il en est sur ses autres énergies
peut-être qu'il faudrait ventiler
l'enveloppe de recherche et
développement alloué à l'énergie d'une
manière à pouvoir se doter des outils de
sa voix qui nous manquent aujourd'hui et
j'en suis assez d'accord et le dernier
point c'est vous nous dites que ça pose
pas de problème de mettre de
l'électricité dans le bâtiment s'ils
sont bien isolés mais aujourd'hui on met
des pompes à chaleur dans des bâtiments
qui ne sont pas isolés et ça pour le
coup ça vient se substituer sur des
énergies qui n'étaient pas des énergies
électriques à la racine donc ça vient
augmenter le besoin énergétique des
bâtiments et ça vient pas du tout enfin
il me semble que c'est non neutre en
fait dans les charges énergétiques qui
viennent et ça c'est quelque chose qui
me semble à prendre en compte donc pour
moi je suis d'accord avec vous si les
bâtiments sont très peu consommateurs et
qu'on met de la pompe à chaleur
effectivement le besoin électrique est
très faible dans un bâtiment neuf ou
dans un bâtiment très bien isolé mais
encore une fois c'est pas le cas dans
des bâtiments qui sont pas isolés donc
il faudrait commencer par l'isolation
avant de mettre des sources énergétiques
des carbonées si on a une maîtrise de
l'énergie en tête
très bien
vous réagir
dans simplement en méthode il appartient
pas aux présidents de de RTE de faire
des commentaires sur la les attributions
de budget dans la politique de recherche
et développement français donc je ne
répondrai pas c'est à cette
interpellation parce que tout simplement
je ce n'est pas ma fonction sur la
géothermie en méthode on a dans le
rapport futur énergétique 2050 prix des
hypothèses de volume de bioénergie donné
par la SNBC dans sa deuxième version qui
comportait un certain nombre de terre de
géothermie mais aussi un certain nombre
de terawater issu de la biomasse
donc on a pris ces données bien
évidemment on a en tête que si la France
n'était pas dans la capacité d'en faire
autant sur dans ce monde des BIOS
énergie l'énergie de substitution ce
serait l'électricité
et donc d'une certaine manière ça ça
nous oblige
à être bon sur les questions
d'électricité sur l'ensemble de vos
questions sur l'isolation
enfin sur la place de l'électricité et
où d'autres vecteurs je vous invite à
vous rapporter au rapport chauffage
système électrique et bâtiment que j'ai
donc évoqué tout à l'heure que nous
avons publié entre 2019 et 2020 mais je
tiens quand même à préciser que cela
fait de nombreuses mandatures que des
gouvernements portent des politiques
d'isolation et de rénovation thermique
il me semble que plusieurs alternances
depuis que la France porte fort et le
plus fort possible des politiques de
maîtrise de la demande au milieu duquel
il y a la question de la rénovation
thermique des logements mais bien et des
logements il y en a donc tellement de
millions que ça peut ça peut pas se
faire en quelques années voilà ce que je
peux vous répondre même la députée merci
je souligne simplement que l'échange que
vous venez d'avoir avec notre
auditionnée était à durée pas loin de 20
minutes
voilà je laisse la parole au président
marlex
merci merci monsieur le Président je
vais quatre questions
la première dont tout le monde découvre
aujourd'hui que le la disponibilité du
parc nucléaire à la commencer
en réalité de manière très claire
depuis 2015
et donc moi je voudrais simplement
savoir d'autant que membre du directoire
de RTE depuis octobre 2015 directeur
général adjoint chargé des réseaux et
des clients quels ont été très
concrètement monsieur le Président vos
alertes et auprès de qui qui sait
préoccupé de cette situation que tout le
monde découvre découvre aujourd'hui de
la baisse régulière continue de la
disponibilité du parc du parc nucléaire
deuxième question
moi je m'intéresse plus aux prévisions
de de RTE à celle dans laquelle l'ADEME
essayer de se de réaliser qui paraissait
plus fantaisiste donc je pense que c'est
extrêmement important d'avoir des
prévisions très fiables
hors quand même c'est assez stupéfiant
de voir les différences de scénarios
qu'on a eu entre les bilans
prévisionnels de RTL en 2015 2017
il y avait un grand titre consommation
électrique des perspectives orientées à
la baisse et où on était sur des
perspectives 3 des 4 scénarios était
orientés à la baisse
il avait un plus
celui qui consommait le plus imaginer le
plus de consommation est à 481 watts
c'est à dire en fait une espèce de
stabilité et sinon 395 RAW en 2035 enfin
vraiment les courbes sont assez
différentes c'est pas vieux c'est en
2017 et vos derniers bilan prévisionnel
2021 là maintenant on est sur des
scénarios moyens 645 en 2020 moi je
comprends pas comment on passe de
scénario on nous dit moins moins
d'électricité et 5 ans après
des scénarios complètement orientés à la
hausse comment comment on peut passer
avec RTE
d'une telle prévision à une autre aussi
aussi facilement on a un peu le
sentiment de ce président quand même que
parfois on a tordu dans ce pays on a
perdu les perspectives pour que ça colle
à une volonté politique et que ça colle
à ce qu'on nous racontait par ailleurs
en moyen de politique publique c'est à
dire puisque il fallait plus faire du
nucléaire qu'il fallait faire des ENR et
bien il fallait que ce soit un peu
crédible et que
le photovoltaïque on allait faire ou
l'éolien qu'on allait faire colle avec
les scénarios d'électricité dont on
aurait besoin simplement on a on a
découvert que la réalité ne serait pas
celle là que tout ça ne tiendrait pas et
c'est ma troisième question ça nous a
amené au virage de Belfort après on a la
République fait un virage à 180° et
décide de relancer des réacteurs et non
plus dans dans fermer
vous avez répondu
à la question de l'allongement de la
durée de vie des centrales moi j'ai un
doute sur le fait que que malgré tout
tout ça colle enfin que qu'on arrive
qu'on arrive à faire face aux besoins
d'électricité donc je pense qu'on aura
besoin d'allonger nos centrales à 60 ans
américains sont à 80 ans donc ça doit
pas être un peu cible il faudra juste de
l'anticiper un tout petit peu cette fois
et ma question sur ce point c'est est-ce
que le scénario tout EPR question très
ouverte pour le coup est-ce que le
scénario tout EPR est le bon scénario
alors il y a la mode des Small réacteurs
est-ce qu'il faut pas revenir à la
production de de réacteurs tel que
modèle Westinghouse troisième génération
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a su faire qu'on
pourrait peut-être faire plus rapidement
en parallèle des en parallèle des EPR et
puis toute dernière question
sur la sur la crise que nous traversons
et notamment la question du prix de
l'électricité dans notre pays est-ce que
vous avez été sollicité par le
gouvernement pour participer à
l'élaboration
scénario je parle d'un scénario
ibérique
en clair qui nous permettra de sortir du
prix de marché du prix du prix de marché
européen spot et qui nous permettra
alors qui obligerait sans doute à
calculer deux prix de marché après le
marché intérieur après moyen de
production intérieure une fois qu'on
aura capté le prix du gazon en France
et qui ne nous interdirait pas de
continuer à faire de l'interconnexion
sur un autre prix de marché donc je
dirais à calculer deux prix de marché
mais est-ce que vous avez été sollicité
par le gouvernement pour travailler un
scénario ibérique et si oui à quelle
date précisément
avez-vous été sollicité
alors monsieur le président
qui s'est occupé de la baisse du
nucléaire qui a constaté la baisse du
nucléaire dans ses fonctions en fait je
crois tout le monde puisque les chiffres
de productive de nucléaire monsieur le
Président ils sont publics et donc ils
sont publics ils sont connus des députés
ils sont connus des ministres ils sont
connus
des pouvoirs publics des pouvoirs privés
la production nucléaire française figure
chaque jour sur un registre transparence
c'est le fonctionnement des marchés qui
veut ça RTE en rencontre dans ces bilans
prévisionnels donc la baisse du
nucléaire que j'ai décrite
c'est pas c'est pas une baisse de
nucléaire qui a été voulue par qui que
ce soit c'est aussi une baisse des Bida
d'EDF et ça fait plaisir à personne moi
je dis juste des faits alors vous m'avez
posé
une question personnelle qui était de
dire qui a alerté alors vous je
ne sais pas qui qui devait alerter qui
en tout cas
donc EDF a un conseil d'administration
qui est supposé suivre le productible du
nucléaire et des performances de
l'opérateur
RTE dans les bilans prisonniers qu'il a
fait comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure a
toujours dit que la baisse de production
nucléaire poserait des problèmes de
marge en revanche non fonctionnellement
entre le premier novembre 2015 et le 31
août 2020 je n'étais pas en charge de
ces sujets et il y avait d'autres
mandataires sociaux en charge de le
faire mais ce n'est pas pour ça que je
n'avais pas confiance de la décrue du
parc nucléaire mais qui est qui est une
question connue et publique simplement
aujourd'hui on passe dans un monde où
tout le monde semble découvrir que le
parc nucléaire a baissé de performance
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait qui va
baisser de performance parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on sait qu'il aura 40 ans
première réponse
vous m'avez posé des questions sur la
manière dont
RTE a projeté des consommations d'un BP
sur l'autre
il y a jamais eu de changement de pied
brutal mais simplement lorsqu'iere fait
des prévisions de consommation on
intègre les politiques publiques à date
et on les tire sur un temps donné bon
et donc il y a eu avant au lendemain de
la crise de 2008 débilant prévisionnel
les premiers qui faisaient le pari sur
une reprise forte parce que c'était
aussi la conjoncture européenne qui
tirait la consommation à la hausse et
ces bilan professionnel
ont montré des courbes qui étaient
plutôt en tendance haussière vous avez
raison je les ai sous les yeux
à partir de 2012-2013 2014 etc les
bilans prévisionnels de RTE ont montré
certaines trajectoires à la baisse et
certaines trajectoires à la hausse avec
toujours une une hypothèse médiane
jusqu'en 2015 et ce n'est qu'en 2017
qu'effectivement l'essentiel des
trajectoires sont à la baisse cela dit
avec un effet rebond d'ailleurs ça
commence par baisser et puis ça remonte
alors pourquoi tout ça je vais juste
détailler ce qui s'est passé entre la
fin des années 2010 c'est 2017 il y a
des politiques et et Madame la Députée
vient d'en parler de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments donc au fur et à
mesure qu'on constate l'efficacité et
les ambitions gouvernementales pour pour
ces politiques de rénovation thermique
et bah ça joue sur la consommation voilà
et donc c'est normal que les projections
de consommation de RTE elle change en
fonction de la manière dont les pouvoirs
publics et dont vous votez des
politiques de rénovation thermique
deuxième élément les questions de
reprise économique
pendant très longtemps on a misé sur des
questions de reprise économique forte
pour ça ça fait quand même longtemps que
la France est dans un monde de
croissance faible et donc ça donc au fur
et à mesure ça c'est des effets sur la
consommation notamment en 2017 on
constatait que les perspectives
industrielles étaient stables en matière
de consommation d'électricité en
revanche il y avait quelque chose qui
avait changé c'est que on a considéré à
l'époque que le que le véhicule
électrique allait avoir son essor et que
oui l'électrification de la mobilité qui
était peu présente dans les bilans
prévisionnels d'avant elle tirait la
conso à la hausse donc vous avez des
phénomènes baissiers plutôt les effets
de maîtrise de l'énergie et plutôt les
effets industriels et à l'époque vous
avez des effets aussi avec effet différé
c'est le déploiement des véhicules
électriques c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous avez dans le bilan
prévisionnel 2017 des consommations qui
commencent par baisser puis qui remonte
c'est l'effet de la mobilité et c'est
l'effet des voeux
pourquoi les choses ont changé dans
futur et déjà stick 2050 parce que je
l'ai dit dans mon introduction
Le Monde du BP 2017 c'est le monde du
Facteur 4 c'est pas le monde de la
neutralité carbone donc c'est pas le
monde de l'électrification absolue c'est
faux c'est un monde dans lequel on
considère le gaz comme une énergie de
transition et c'est un monde dans lequel
il reste des fossiles en 2050 et c'est
pas un monde dans lequel on
passe à l'électricité presque à tout
prix parce que le seul complément
énergétique qu'on a d'ici 2050 c'est
selon moi parlé avec vous Madame c'est
les bioénergie et donc effectivement ça
ça limite fini que ce soit la géothermie
ou la biomasse française donc oui ce
n'est pas les mêmes hypothèses et c'est
normal monsieur le Président que RTE est
montré des courbes qui changent
je passe à Belfort non excusez-moi
vous avez donc évoqué le fait qu'on
aurait demandé à donc RTE 2 montrer des
tendances de consommation baissière pour
justifier le fait qu'il y aurait 50 % de
production nucléaire alors ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que ce n'est pas
vrai pour deux raisons déjà les 50% de
production de nucléaires c'est 50% de
production c'est pas 50% de consommation
donc que la France consomme 50 ou 100
si la loi se disait que c'était 50% de
production c'était 50% de production sur
le sol français et ça n'a rien à voir
avec la consommation il y a pas de
et puis je vais vous dire une deuxième
chose parce que moi je tiens des fentes
cette entreprise que j'ai l'honneur de
deider et je souhaite pas laisser penser
que on travaille sous la dictée de
quiconque on a on a on a fait la
démonstration monsieur le Président dans
funéraire génétique 2050
dans le complément qu'on a publié en
février
que l'avantage économique à faire du
nouveau nucléaire en France de 10
milliards d'euros par an
il existe dans un scénario sobriété
et il existe dans un scénario
réindustrialisation profonde je
m'explique que la France consomme
térawattheure d'électricité en 2050
c'est-à-dire très peu
qu'elle consomme conformément à notre
scénario médian de 650 terawatters en
2050 ou qu'elle consomme 750 térawatters
l'avantage à faire du nouveau nucléaire
et toujours de 10 milliards d'euros par
an nous l'avons dit nous l'avons
présenté nous l'avons publié
donc l'avantage du nouveau nucléaire ne
dépend pas de la trajectoire de
consommation France dans les scénarios
que nous avons publié qu'on assume donc
il faut une bonne fois pour toutes se
détacher de l'idée que
projeter des trajectoires de
consommation qui seraient trop hautes ou
trop basse joue sur l'avantage à faire
du nouveau nucléaire nous avons démontré
que sur le plan économique c'était
avantageux de faire du nouveau nucléaire
et je constate aussi j'en profite parce
que j'ai la parole que il y a plein
de lobby on va dire de gens qui sont
qui se sentent
pour défendre le nucléaire que personne
ne veut fermer par principe ni RTE ni
voilà
de projeter des consommations très
hautes en disant bah je parie sur une
consommation très haute pour justifier
le fait qu'on fasse du nucléaire mais en
fait on a montré qu'on n'avait pas
besoin de ça le nouveau nucléaire sur le
plan économique il se justifie même si
la France est très sobre
et puis vous avez vous m'avez interrogé
sur
sur le scénario toute paire alors bon je
vous dire que tous nos scénarios sont
pas toutes pairs parce que comme vous
levez noté il y a donc donc le scénario
N3 de futur énergétique de 1050 qui
dispose qu'en plus de pairs il y a des
SMS donc en fait le sous-jacent c'est
New World c'est New World c'est le
modèle
dont
DF a pris la tête et qui avec la avec la
collaboration d'arriva ta donc technique
atome désormais
pour 4 gigawatts ça fait beaucoup de SMS
parce que New World a priori chaque
réacteur New World fait 170 mégawatts
donc pour faire
pour en faire pour en faire 4000 il en
faut beaucoup et puis nous avons
pris l'hypothèse
de prolonger 8 gigawatts de réacteurs
au-delà de 60 ans est-ce qu'on aurait dû
est-ce qu'on aurait pu poser l'hypothèse
d'un autre type de réacteur
je pense je que vous évoquez par exemple
l'atma qui avait été un projet de 1000
MW porté au début des années 2010 par
engie par Areva et par Mitsubishi
je
il me semble que c'est un petit peu tard
c'est-à-dire que les durées de
développement d'un réacteur nucléaire
sont très longues mais que aujourd'hui
il y a un projet de 1000 MW la France
n'en a pas le basique design en tout cas
d'un mille megawatts de troisième
génération
il me semble que c'est important que la
France développe des réacteurs
nucléaires qu'elle
maîtrise elle-même c'est une question de
souveraineté technologique
et donc je crois d'une certaine manière
que pour 2050 c'est un peu tard pour
envisager remplacer des EPS par un mille
megawatts dont on aurait ni le basique
design il y a fortiori le die tail
design
parce que 2050 c'est dans 28 ans et
c'est une course contre la montre et que
d'une certaine manière on peut se dire
que le nucléaire confort d'ici 2050
c'est le nucléaire qu'on a aujourd'hui
déjà développé en France et donc c'est
essentiellement LEPR et New World qui
est un
smmr lui aussi
développer par des français et pour
finir je souhaite effectivement mais là
c'est pas je ne parle pas en tant que
président ou peut-être en tant que
citoyen puisque vous m'interpellez aussi
là dessus je souhaiterais effectivement
que pour des raisons de souveraineté
d'indépendance les technologies
nucléaires qui sont implantées en France
soit des technologies françaises et de
ce point de vue dès lors que je constate
que la France n'a pas de réacteur 1000
MW sur étagère on prend le Pr qui est le
choix que la France a fait jusqu'à
nouvel ordre pour sa troisième
génération
le général de Gaulle c'est contenté de
Westinghouse donc pas besoin non plus de
mettre la barre trop
soudainement en matière en matière
nucléaire vous avez pas répondu ma
dernière question monsieur le Président
sur l'étude d'un scénario ibérique
excusez-moi vous je confirme que le
gouvernement nous a bien commandé des
études économiques sur la simulation
d'un
ibérique appliquée à l'ensemble de
l'Europe je confirme
non
je vous confirme que
l'État nous a bien demandé de simuler
d'un point de vue économique la mise en
oeuvre d'un mécanisme ibérique dès lors
qu'il serait appliqué à l'ensemble des
pays européens puisque nous avions
démontré mais ça c'était facile à faire
qu'un mécanisme ibérique qui ne serait
appliquer qu'à la France crée un effet
de fuite et en fait était
péjorant pour la France en fait nous
avons fait des études économiques aussi
pour aider le gouvernement à soutenir
l'hypothèse d'un mécanisme ibérique qui
serait étendu à l'ensemble des pays
européens puisque c'était le seul moyen
de rendre de rendre performance ce
mécanisme de baisse des prix de
l'électricité en passant par la par la
baisse du prix du gaz qui rentre dans
les centrales à gaz en revanche je n'ai
pas
en mémoire la date de cette commande
c'est au mois d'octobre mais je n'ai
plus la date mais monsieur le Président
je me ferai un plaisir de vous de vous
transmettre l'information
précise pardon juste le président le
permet
l'intérêt du scénario uberique serait
genre pour pour la France scénario
ibérique consisterait donc à caper du
prix du prix du gaz en France
le subventionné on sait que ça aurait
coûté à peu près 5 milliards pour une
année entière pour calculer un prix de
production de l'électricité en France
une fois les productions moyen en
gardant l'arrêt de la règle du méritorer
une fois capé le prix du le prix du gaz
fait de production moyen d'électricité
en France fortement impacté par le
nucléaire à 50 euros le mégawatt un peu
moins pour le hydroélectricité donc on
serait sans doute très loin des 550
euros du prix de marché spot
bon je comprends bien que notre absence
d'indépendance pose problème fait qu'on
importe l'électricité anglaise
pardon pose pose une difficulté mais si
cet été nous retrouverons la plénitude
de notre capacité de production
nucléaire la question elle pourra se
poser
produire une électricité un prix de
marché de 50 euros de mégawattheure une
fois subventionné les 5 milliards de gaz
c'est pas la même chose économiquement
pour nos entreprises que d'aller
l'acheter sur les marchés à 550 euros ou
d'avoir ou d'avoir le pour l'État avoir
le subventionné à coup de dizaines de
milliards donc sincèrement ça mériterait
que vous expliquer un peu plus votre
votre analyse
excusez-moi monsieur le Président je
vais essayer de faire bref
l'électricité elle transite entre les
pays il y a des interconnexions et vous
connaissez le principe de la formation
des prix le marché donc un marché
marginalisme l'offre croise la demande
au niveau au niveau de l'Europe et le
pricing de l'électricité en France
dépend la plupart du temps du coup
marginal de production d'une centrale à
gaz à l'étranger
voilà
et donc le sujet épatant de faire
baisser le coût marginal de production
d'une centrale à gaz en France parce
qu'une centrale à gaz en France est une
centrale assez moderne assez performante
et elle a donc un rendement meilleur que
les vieilles qui sont à l'étranger mais
en fait l'idée était bien qu'on fasse
baisser le coût de la centrale marginale
à gaz qui
impacte le prix en Europe et en France
donc
sauf à fermer les interconnexions
électriques et à suspendre le marché de
l'électricité donc
oui l'idée était bien d'appliquer le
mécanisme ibérique à l'ensemble des pays
de l'Europe puisque en plafonnant le
prix du gaz utilisé pour faire de
l'électricité ça allait faire baisser le
prix de la centrale marginale qui forme
le prix
sur les marchés spot
et qui est et vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que les prix forwards les prix à
terme sont des extrapolations des
moyennes des prises potes donc en fait
ce qui compte c'est de faire en sorte
que
ce soit donc à la fois les prises potes
et les forwards qui baissent donc oui il
n'aurait il n'aurait pas eu
cela n'aurait pas eu de sens à ce que
nous n'appliquons le mécanisme ibérique
qu'en France que si vous ne l'aviez fait
qu'en France ça aurait coûté obligé de
l'État et au contribuable très cher de
subventionner du gaz
sur le Président je vais
je vais aller au bout de la compétence
de RTE et je vais m'arrêter là et je ne
suis pas compétences sur les questions
budgétaires mais simplement
le principe selon lequel la France
subventionnaire est seul
le gaz qui rentre dans ces centrales à
gaz
donc ça ça lui coûterait pendant qu'elle
continuerait à subir la formation des
prises potes
comme d'habitude parce que nos pays
voisins n'ont pas fait la même chose et
nous indexons des prix de l'électricité
sur la centrale marginale qui n'est pas
en France ça veut dire que c'est de
l'argent public qu'on dépense pour rien
c'est à dire que
dès lors que c'est une centrale à gaz
qui était étrangère qui fixe le prix de
l'électricité en France c'est le prix de
cette centrale là qu'il faut faire
baisser et non pas la centrale française
puisque c'est presque jamais la
centrale française qui fixe le prix et
c'est ça que nous avons démontré c'est
ça que nous avons étudié voilà après je
je
reste à ma place et je ne me permettrai
pas de rentrer dans des débats qui
relèvent de cette assemblée le
gouvernement nous a pas demandé donc
d'étudier un scénario à libérer pour la
France que comme scénario dans lequel
chaque pays reprend
mais fais calculer obtient la dérogation
de Bruxelles pour calculer son prix de
marché en fonction de ses moyens de
production propre
donc ça non vous n'avez pas étudié
le prix de marché de l'électricité ou le
prix de marché du gaz
alors non le gouvernement nous a demandé
d'étudier des effets du mécanisme
hybride et nous avons montré un que si
la France le mettait en œuvre seul que
ça génère des grandes pertes et un grand
désavantage pour la France et du coup
nous l'avons simulé à l'échelle
européenne et nous avons démontré que ce
pourrait être une solution à condition
que l'ensemble des pays européens
concernés l'adopte ce qui a ma
connaissance n'a pas été le cas merci
Madame Leernes
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez me confirmer que
tous les scénarios y compris le plus
nucléarisé demande de développer de
manière significative les énergies
renouvelables
je vous le confirme
et donc par opposition il souligne qu'il
serait possible de se passer des
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
c'est une question aussi je vous ai dit
que tous nos scénarios permettaient la
sécurité d'approvisionnement donc oui
des scénarios 100% renouvelables sont
techniquement accessibles même s'ils
sont très difficiles il faut pas se il
faut pas se il faut pas se mentir sur la
difficulté du chemin
très bien il me semblait important pour
notre commission d'enquête d'entendre
cela basé sur les choses justement pour
atteindre le scénario 100% énergies
renouvelable
on a interrogé votre un de vos
prédécesseurs monsieur Bretz hier sur
les investissements nécessaires
notamment dans l'évolution des réseaux
quel que soit d'ailleurs les scénarios
retenus mais j'imagine que le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas une option très claire qui
soit retenue d'une manière ou d'une
autre ne facilite pas un gestionnaire de
réseau puisque on voit bien l'évolution
qui serait nécessaire donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire s'il y a eu déjà
assez d'investissements avec les 30
milliards qu'on a évoqué hier sur
l'évolution des réseaux nécessaires ça
c'est une première question et puis
peut-être nous en dire un peu plus sur
le système de Smart Grids sur lequel
travaille RTE notamment le projet Ringo
qui Sauveur de ma part viserait à
répondre à l'intermittence de l'éolien
et du photovoltaïque au pic de
production sans avoir pour autant à
construire de nouvelles lignes à haute
tension
est-ce que cela permettrait
effectivement d'absorber et d'avoir un
réseau 100%
renouvelable une question aussi sur la
résilience des réseaux face aux effets
du changement climatique est-ce que vous
avez prévu ça aussi dans les
investissements
voilà les les principales questions sur
les réseaux et j'en aurai une
subsidiaire sur la question de la
cybersécurité
il semblerait que il y ait eu des
failles qui étaient constatées sur la
cybersécurité notamment que avec une
ligne de commande tapées dans un
ordinateur dépourvu de mot de passe il
aurait été possible de programmer un
bloc-out un blackout excusez-moi et que
RTE aurait mandaté un cabinet
d'expertise dans ce sens est-ce que ces
failles sur la cybersécurité ont été
également résolus ils font partie
j'imagine de vos préoccupations
merci madame la députée je vais
commencer par cette dernière question
sur la cybercule sécurité je suppose que
vous évoquez une affaire qui s'est passé
à Valenciennes donc pour laquelle 4 des
salariés de RTE sont à la fois sous le
coup d'une enquête préliminaire
digiantée par le parquet de Paris et
sous le coup d'une procédure
disciplinaire pourquoi parce que c'est
des agents qui sont habilités formés à
rentrer dans des systèmes d'information
sécurisés c'est un information sur des
systèmes d'information critiques qui
dépendent de la loi de programmation
militaire qui ne sont pas ouverts à tous
les ans je vous confirme que ce n'est
pas possible d'y rentrer sans mot de
passe mais effectivement nos salariés en
tout cas certains d'entre eux sont qui
sont Dumont habilités à le faire on
l'autorisation de rentrer dans ce si de
maintenance parce que bah en fait c'est
leur travail vous et moi il peut nous
arriver d'avoir des droits d'accès à des
si sensibles en fonction de notre
travail en fait pour nos salariés
c'est la même chose et donc lorsqu'il
s'avère que certains de ces salariés
rentrent dans un système d'information
critique pour
ecommet des actes qui sont pas normaux
voire illégaux et bien on dépose plainte
et on les et il rentre dans une dans une
dans une procédure discipleinaire tout
ça est bien normal
on est un service public et stratégique
pour l'État on est très protégé on
travaille beaucoup avec Annecy on fait
très attention à ça et si donc
d'aventure vous aviez besoin d'une
garantie sur la nature de nos
protections je vous invite
à ce qu'on puisse en reparler à huis
clos madame la députée compte tenu de la
sensibilité du sujet et qu'on puisse
vous faire la démonstration de tout le
travail réalisé avec les services
spécialisés français qui s'occupent de
la lutte contre le cyber terrorisme donc
ça c'était
la première question
alors vous avez donc évoqué des
investissements sur les autres
transports là je change de je change de
sujet sans transition pardonnez-moi
on est de l'ordre 35 milliards d'euros
d'investissement sur le réseau public de
transport d'ici 2035 on n'est pas du
tout à l'échéance de 1050 de futurs
énergétiques les 35 milliards dont je
crois le présidentiel une berger à
parler à moins que ce soit le rapporteur
Armand était était à une échéance
finalement presque court terme bien
évidemment les volumes donc donc
[Musique]
qu'on aura besoin d'en investir d'ici
2050 pour atteindre un ordre de grandeur
de pour être
[Musique]
50 90 milliards mais en fait ça dépend
beaucoup des des scénarios qui sont
retenus parce que il vous a pas échappé
que un scénario de mixe de production
dans lequel on construit beaucoup de pr
qui est une source de production
concentrée qu'on localiserait au même
endroit que les centrales nucléaires
actuelles nous oblige pas à construire
beaucoup plus de réseau en tout cas
ça nécessite moins d'investissement
qu'un monde où on fait beaucoup
d'énergie renouvelable avec des grands
parcs terrestres et des grands parcs
offshore où là vous avez un budget
raccordement absolument conséquent alors
moi je porte pas le jugement sur ce qui
préférable de faire ou pas mais
simplement la nature des installations
de production et surtout le l'endroit où
vous voulez localiser ben en fait joue
pour beaucoup
dans dans les trajectoires
d'investissement mais ce sera en toute
hypothèse plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros d'ici 2050 ce qui
conduit donc RTE à avoir des
perspectives d'investissement par an
aujourd'hui en 2023 donc RTE va mettre
un milliard entre un milliard 8 et un
milliard 9 donc d'investissement nous
allons dépasser dans quelques années les
deux milliards par an et on dépassera en
203230 les 3 milliards d'euros par an
probablement pour peut-être dépasser les
4 milliards d'euros par an à entre 2040
et 2050 donc oui c'est une trajectoire
ascendante mais on savait que les effets
de la transition énergétique est presque
quelle que soit le chemin que l'on
retient nécessiterait des
investissements réseau absolument
conséquents
vous nous avez parlé vous m'avez
interrogé sur est-ce qu'on se préoccupe
de de la résilience c'est du chemin et
du chemin et du changement climatique
pardon oui dans le futur énergétique je
suis vous avez feuilleté ou lu avec
attention l'étude et vous avez vu que
nous avons intégré des stress test
notamment le scénario
RCP 8.5 qui était un scénario du laisser
faire climatique et qui génère des
dérives climatiques avec des
conséquences bulles de chaux bulle de
froid qui ont qui ont à la fois un
impact sur la manière dont les Français
consomment et les Européens consomment
mais aussi sur la la capacité du
matériel à tenir des très fortes de
température mais aussi à se poser la
question de où est-ce qu'il faudrait que
la France implante d'éventuelles
nouvelles tranches nucléaire qui elle
doivent être refroidies enfin qui
utilise des prises d'eau
pour produire de l'électricité donc ça
oui nous a monté du point de vue de
notre rôle en tant que gestionnaire
d'actifs oui nous avons un plan de
gestion du changement climatique dans
lequel nous intégrons l'ensemble de ce
qui évolue dès à présent des périodes de
canicule qui sont plus fortes qu'avant
et qui nous conduisent à exploiter les
lignes différemment parce que ça nous
conduit à baisser l'intensité de l'élit
des lignes parce qu'on a du mal à donc
additionner dilatation dû à la chaleur
de l'électricité plus dilatation due à
la chaleur de la météo
nous traitons aussi les événements
d'inondation depuis sevenol
les tempêtes bien évidemment donc les
phénomènes de vent et enfin les les
hypothèses par exemple de neige de neige
coland qui vous savez peuvent
générer des coupures donc oui la
question est inscrite
monitorer et d'ores et déjà nous avons
des programmes d'augmentation de la
résilience du réseau du fait de la
changement de son environnement
climatique pour faire simple
et puis le projet Ringo alors le projet
Ringo est un projet qui qui visait à
c'est finalement c'est un projet de
ligne virtuelle c'est l'idée de de
stocker l'énergie
la production d'énergie renouvelable dès
lors que la ligne qui permet de
l'évacuer normalement et saturer donc ce
serait c'est une batterie qui stocke
finalement le surplus produite par des
installations d'énergie renouvelables et
qui re libère cette énergie quand on en
a besoin
[Musique]
donc le bilan est bon simplement
RTE n'a pas le droit d'être un acteur de
stockage tout simplement parce qu'être
un acteur de stockage c'est avoir une
influence sur le marché d'électricité et
qu'en tant que gestionnaire du réseau de
transport et d'exploitant du système
électrique n'avons pas le droit d'avoir
une influence sur les marchés sur les
prix
donc nous avons fait ça à titre
expérimental ça a été financé par la
craie nous avons fait ça au titre de
plein de plein de sujets de R&D que nous
conduisons nous défrichons un certain
nombre de domaines technologique Ringo
en fait partie si d'aventure on fait un
bilan économique et technique qui sera
positif et bien tant mieux la France
sera montré qu'il y avait des
dispositifs techniques qui pourront
faire l'objet demain d'investissement
privé et donc ce rôle de défricheur
aussi de solutions technologiques nous
le faisons sur le stockage nous le
faisons sur le contrôle commande nous le
faisons sur plein de domaines et notre
souhait c'est que une fois que nous vont
montrer qu'il y avait un modèle
économique et de la place pour de
l'investissement et bien la France
puisse investir dans ces technologies
qui servent la transition énergétique de
demain
qui a déjà été évoqué en partie par ma
collègue
madame millefer c'est la question la
thermosensibilité française qui a été
souligné par plusieurs d'autres
dictionnaires avant vous d'une typicité
française
monsieur Levy hier indiquait que c'était
quelque chose de positif par rapport à
la souveraineté énergétique française
est-ce que pour vous en tant que
gestionnaire de réseau aussi ça ne
constitue pas une fragilité dans la
mesure où pour le fait qu'il y ait
beaucoup de chauffage électrique
notamment et cette thermosensibilité
n'induit-elle pas le fait qu'on soit
plus fragile face au Pic au moment de
froid et de grande consommation
française est un fait
et oui vous avez raison c'est plus la
courbe de charge d'une journée et
pointu plus ça vous oblige à
dimensionner le système électrique à la
pointe de toute façon le but c'est de
couvrir la consommation des Français à
chaque seconde de la journée bon donc
plus votre courbe de charge est lissé et
prévisible
plus vous pouvez prévoir des moyens de
production en conséquence c'est plus
pour le gestionnaire de réseau c'est
confortable mais si vous avez une courbe
de charge avec des pointes de
consommation électrique très haute ça
vous oblige de à dimensionner l'outil de
production en fonction de cette pointe
et effectivement donc à la fin c'est
cher
donc en tendance lisser les pointes
donc le plateau du matin et la pointe du
soir
c'est à la fois plus facile à gérer sur
le système électrique et ce sera moins
cher sur la facture des Français donc je
vois pas en quoi ce sera une bonne
nouvelle d'avoir des pointes très hautes
en revanche le fait qu'on soit
thermosensible
et je m'arrête sur ce terme
c'est ni bien animal le sujet c'est ce
qu'on a le système électrique en face
pour pour le gérer vous voyez enfin la
thermosensibilité n'appelle pas de
commentaires particulièrement en fait ce
qui compte c'est est-ce qu'on sait
d'immotionner en face le parc de
production ou les outils de flexibilité
qui permettent de le traiter j'insiste
au moindre coût pour les Français et ça
c'est très important
merci beaucoup monsieur Dubois
oui merci monsieur le président
j'aurai une question je voudrais revenir
sur les scénarios et les études vous
nous dites que
tous vos scénarios et vos études sont
savantes scientifiques celles qui sont
produites
et vous partez sur des mixtes donc 70 à
80 % ENR et jusqu'à 100% ENR pour aller
chercher notamment la décoration à
l'horizon 2050
les études scientifiques prouvent bien
que l'électricité bas carbone et issue
de l'hydroélectricité et du nucléaire
donc
je voudrais que vous m'expliquez comment
on peut sur un 100% donc ENR aller
chercher le 0 donc
carbone à partir du moment où
vous nous avez dit également que
l'hydroélectricité il n'était pas
possible
ou très difficile d'en faire davantage
alors que c'est l'électricité ENR donc
la plus bas carbone pourtant vos études
à l'horizon 2050 dans vos scénarios
prévoit donc 5 gigawatts à l'horizon
2050 d'hydroélectricité donc 3 gigawatts
en step
donc vous avez affirmé tout à l'heure
que il y avait pas de possibilité de de
d'hydroélectricité supplémentaire et je
voudrais également par rapport aux
problèmes des usages et aux décisions
politiques savoir si vous remettez en
cause vos scénarios même si ils sont les
études sont savantes
parce que tout prouve que depuis et vous
l'avez dit depuis donc 2013 à 2014
avec les différentes décisions
politiques les lois de 2015 je passe
pour aller plus vite
et on en arrive en 2022 à perdre donc
notre souveraineté énergétique donc moi
ça m'interroge et ça me fait même peur
que vos autres vous études à l'horizon
2005 ans
nous condamne à une perte de
souveraineté encore plus importante
puisque les à la fois les conflits
d'usage et les décisions politiques font
que vos scénarios ne traînent pas et
votre ne tiennent pas et que votre
sécurité ne tient pas puisque nous avons
perdu la souveraineté
je vais commencer par répondre à votre
première question sur le mix énergétique
qui tente vers 100% renouvelable
dans nos mixtes qui tentent vers 100%
renouvelable en 2050 il y a énormément
d'énergie enouvelables j'en ai donné les
multiplicatifs enfin les les facteurs
tout à l'heure
et donc tout ça c'est de la production
de bas carbone c'est de la production
qui n'aimait pas de carbone lorsqu'on
produit de l'électricité parce qu'en
fait on fait un raccourci on parle de
production bas carbone en fait tous les
moyens de production d'eau d'électricité
même les plus performants ont une
empreinte carbone parce que tout
simplement le matériau avec lequel ils
sont construits à une empreinte carbone
une centrale nucléaire comme une
éolienne comme un panneau solaire à une
empreinte carbone parce que tout
simplement il faut le fabriquer bon
je vois qu'on a dit ça
l'ensemble des moyens qu'on a mis dans
nos scénarios tous sans aucune exception
n'émettent pas de CO2 lorsqu'il
fonctionne ce soit du nucléaire ou ce
soit des éoliennes ou ce soit du solaire
en fait où ce soir de l'hydroélectricité
donc ça vous pouvez en avoir la garantie
on a on a travaillé des mixes
électriques j'ai dit qu'ils avaient des
avantages et des inconvénients et qui
représentaient des défis assez
différents selon que vous faisiez du
nouveau nucléaire ou pas il y en ait
aucun très facile à vrai dire
mais si on voulait être neutre en
carbone il fallait il fallait qu'on
passe par là et que nous on garantissait
le fait que ce serait notre en carbone
alors non on a pris plus hydraulique que
ce que vous avez dit on a pris en base
on a 22 gigawatts d'hydraulique dans
dans futures énergétique et 8 gigawatts
de step
donc ça fait donc voilà vous avez donc
évoqué 5 GW je voulais vous vous
précisez ça et puis vous m'avez
interpellé sur le fait qu'en 2022 on
perdait notre souveraineté donc
énergétique et donc permettez-moi de
vous dire que je de mon point de vue je
ne vois pas en quoi en 2022 la France a
perdu
sa souveraineté énergétique parce que le
problème de la souveraineté donc
énergétique de la France c'est le fait
qu'elle consomme que 63% de l'énergie
que la France consomme c'est du pétrole
et du gaz et que cette situation elle
date pas de 2022 elle date de dis à très
longtemps et que le problème de la
souveraineté française c'est d'où vient
ce pétrole et ce gaz
et si on nous coupe l'approvisionnement
donc en pétrole et du gaz qu'est-ce qui
se passe
bon alors
on aurait perdu notre notre souveraineté
donc électrique en
je ne crois pas le système électrique
français en contre les difficultés du
fait de du manque de de productible
nucléaire
ce problème demande de productible
nucléaire il est
il est repéré
parce que c'est essentiellement dû à
corrosion sous contrainte il est
technique il est réparable et eDF va
réparer le parc nucléaire français donc
nous traversons oui quelques années
probablement jusqu'en 2025 de tension
sur le système électrique parce que le
parc nucléaire français est dominant et
qui la rencontrer un défaut qu'il faut
réparer mais en fait la pathologie est
connue elle est repérée
EDF est en train de faire les travaux
d'ailleurs l'essentiel des des 12
tranches qui avait été les premières
concernées par cette corrosion ont été
traitées donc nous sommes dans un monde
où oui le parc nucléaire a rencontré
donc une difficulté oui ce n'est pas
très agréable d'avoir à vivre ça
ni comme représentant du peuple français
que vous êtes ni comme gestionnaire de
réseau qui garantit la sécurité
d'approvisionnement avec un tel manque
de une production sur lequel nous
n'avons pas de levier
mais oui c'est une c'est une difficulté
technique c'est transitoire c'est
réparable la France va le réparer donc
je ne partage pas votre appréciation que
la France a perdu quelque chose en 2022
en revanche je partage avec vous que
que cette situation est tendue et que
notre enjeu collectif aujourd'hui c'est
de passer l'hiver qui vient sans coupure
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y avait
un plan sobriété c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons lancé notre
application Ecowatt pour que les
Français les entreprises et les
collectivités réagissent au bon moment
et c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
année nous sommes bien contents de
disposer de beaucoup d'interconnexions
parce que jusqu'à présent les
interconnexions entre la France et les
pays voisins avaient été utilisé par la
France pour exporter du nucléaire donc
ça avait fait le chiffre d'affaires des
Français on exportait notre électr ça
c'était bon pour notre balance
notre balance du commerce extérieur
j'étais bon pour les comptes d'EDF et
c'était bon pour la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de l'Europe parce
que ça aidait les autres à garantir leur
propre sécurité d'approvisionnement et
la France historiquement a toujours été
très exportatrice et de ce point de vue
les interconnexions c'est une très bonne
c'est une très bonne idée parce que ça
permet finalement l'équilibre économique
d'un pays qui a beaucoup de nucléaires
et qui a pas besoin d'électricité tout
le temps voilà
et ben pour une fois ces
intercollections qui nous servaient
finalement à
donc exporter notre nucléaire pour une
fois ça nous sert dans l'autre sens et
oui cet hiver au-delà des efforts qu'il
faut faire sur la consommation nous
utiliserons beaucoup d'importations
parce qu'on fera venir de l'électricité
depuis nos pays voisins ça c'est une
question une question de solidarité
entre pays européens qui interne et
fondement d'ailleurs de la coopération
entre les gestionnaires de réseau pour
ma part j'ai l'honneur de prise celui
qui est français voilà Monsieur le
Député parce que je pourrais vous
répondre à votre interpellation
vous avez pas répondu sur sur le
phénomène que effectivement
il y a des imprévus dans vous avez
exprimé par rapport
aux problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte au niveau du nucléaire il y
avait quand même des choses qu'on
pouvait anticiper notamment pour toutes
celles qui sont arrêtées pour
maintenance de réseau
est-ce que dans vous n'avez pas répondu
à la question sur sur les problématiques
et qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui dans vos
scénarios donc à l'horizon 2035 ou 2050
est-ce que vous recoligez vos scénarios
avec les imprévus qu'on découvre
aujourd'hui et qui était sûrement pas
pris en considération dans vos études
préalables
alors c'était déjà non on intègre pas un
défaut générique parce qu'en fait le
défaut générique sur toutes les tranches
françaises ou sur la moitié des tranches
françaises c'est une forme de c'est une
forme de scénario presque catastrophe et
c'est
c'est la queue de probabilité en
revanche dans nos scénarios bien
évidemment on fait baisser
le productible donc le volume
d'électricité produit par le nucléaire
français en moyenne on le fait baisser
avec le temps tout simplement parce
qu'on intègre l'âge voilà donc oui on
intègre l'effet âge sur le parc
nucléaire français dans nos scénarios et
les études que vous avez lu elles
intègrent à l'effetage dans
dans les questions de sécurité d'appro
française en revanche nous on ne simule
pas un incident de type toutes les
tranches nucléaires sont à l'arrêt ou la
moitié sont à l'arrêt parce que là on
sait très bien que du point de vue de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement on est dans
un dans un autre monde on est dans dans
un ordre de grandeur complètement
différent mais oui on intègre bien des
pathologies régulières des effets d'âge
qui font que le parc nucléaire français
vieilli et que
d'une certaine manière on peut avoir une
quasi certitude qu'il aura des
difficultés à reproduire 400 ttwatts par
an dans les années qui viennent mais
c'est pas parce que il aura des
difficultés à reproduire 400 terwatts
par an qu'il ne faut pas qu'ils se le
fit qu'il se le fixe comme objectif
et merci Monsieur piéchaik pour cette
audition qui aura été complète
qui démontre que non seulement les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
sont scrutés à l'extérieur font parler
en ville mais que on trouve toujours un
certain nombre de de questionnements de
questions et parfois de discussions
assez précises à avoir avec nos
auditionnés successifs je vous remercie
pour votre disponibilité pour pour vous
répondre je donne aux membres de la
commission d'enquête rendez-vous cet
après-midi pour la poursuite de nos
travaux bon appétit à tous merci à vous